[Music]
i can't wait forever i'm not that
patient i got too many things to do
you're comfy like a sweater but when the
sun comes out
[Music]
that is
i'll share with you if you're so
[Music]
i cry
me
[Music]
[Applause]
i can't wait forever
[Music]
i
have tried my best
[Music]
when you were here with me
i know it's been so
[Music]
i'm many trapped beneath my
fears
[Music]
face
cold from
lack of skin
fighting what's within
[Music]
me
know it's been so
[Music]
and many you've changed
i'm afraid to say
[Music]
the words you let us stray
i'm expected
to
pursue
[Music]
a bond
that i thought i was
[Music]
[Applause]
i know it's been so
[Music]
and if you have an imprint
face
[Music]
happy halloween everybody
i have a cake
hello hello who have we got here who are
the early birds to the stream
hey kevin deacon
hey sidnator
hello alan lomas
hello
ib196
hello riser
hello i like press i like press i like
press buttons
uh hey
jamie
and uh yeah welcome to the halloween
stream
we're gonna have a lot of fun today um
we have uh the schedule is from now
until quarter to 5 pm bst we're just
going to be chatting and singing some
songs
a nice chill way to start the halloween
stream and then later on i'm going to
come back at 5 p.m
play a bit of fatal frame
uh the remake that just got
remade although i've read that um it has
quite a few bugs and stuff so i tried to
fix them yesterday but we'll see how
that goes and uh yeah frame's supposed
to be very scary so hopefully
more than likely i'm going to scream
scream quite a lot
um
and then at 8 p.m
i'm playing some games with some friends
so we got a long long stream and as you
can see up here we are raising the money
for charity the link is in the
description down below uh also stream
labs will be reminded you of that link
we're raising money for women's trust
um you know
abuse domestic violence all that stuff
they really help
people get through times that are
extremely hard and situations that are
very difficult to run away from
unfortunately it happens far far too
often so i think it's a wonderful
charity for us to be raising toward
today i've already put in a little 15
pounds but if you have any money that
can go towards them
it would be very much appreciated the
link is also up here it's justgiving.com
yagmanx halloween and i will put it in
the chat now as well
so
there you go
ah so before i start singing does anyone
have any i don't think i don't know how
long we get
to keep this cape on because it's so big
it keeps getting like caught to
everything but how cool is it oh i think
i just like it's like i'm a little
caterpillar i've been walking around in
this all day today
and
the hood is so big as well
like an old hag
that is what they used to call witches
um
autumn red nice outfit you look great do
you have a witch hat yes i do
i threw it off my head because i wanted
to put the hood of this cape on but yes
this is my final form
very scary
jake is like what are you doing i don't
know
i don't know
i tried to decorate for you i don't know
how well you can see but there's like a
little pumpkin down there
candles
um that candle up there is actually a
little cauldron which is quite cool it's
like a wax melter and it melts the wax
which is in a tiny cauldron which is
cool there's something that i put there
but you can't even see it it's like
above
it's a little uh cauldron
but you can't even see it
and then you know the drill if you put
in an exclamation mark and some
special magic words the lights change
color so
feel free to try it
and a hood nice wait my cloak's choking
me so
i need to sit on it differently
yeah i don't i don't know how long we're
going to keep this clip on today
but it's very cool it's very cool
so yeah who has some cool halloween
plans let me know them i want to see
them in the chat right now
i said it's a hashtag hag
no
do you have your cauldron bowl yes
i i should actually be i'll be eating
from that later on because i'm going to
have soup
in my second break i'm going to have
some soup from my cauldron bowl so that
way that'll be fun
that will be fun
i
tired earlier
hashtag halloween i should have put that
on the lights
if they're not working by the way then
oh well we tried it should be working
oh
it's logged out of twitch oh darn sorry
only you youtube people can use it for
some reason
oh it's probably because of the twitch
you know when when all of the uh
passwords got linked
so i signed out of everything and
changed her password
[Music]
oh well let's just carry on what we're
doing
um
i'll fix i'll fix it for for later when
i come back
prepare for a monday lecture the
scariest sunday of all
what lecture are you doing kieran what
kind of lecture halloween party at six
i'm green is joel from less of us that's
cool sidnator
nice i hope you have an ellie
that would be even cooler
hey blixy
okay
should we play some songs let's let's
play some songs
we're gonna start with the ukulele
[Music]
do
so how does this go yep
[Music]
in the cool of the evening when
everything is
[Music]
guessing i is
really know what you are thinking
[Music]
i get
confused with a spooky little boy
and if you decide someday to stop this
[Music]
and now i know
you are what you see
like
[Music]
is
i yes know how to end that one because
in the original song it just kind of
fades out so in the cover i did last
year i literally just
went around for ages and then in the
post i just faded out
but yeah first
that one's always nice and fun to sing
what type of music do you like
the answer that everyone gives is like a
bit of everything but it is true it's
kind of like what you're into isn't it
i like
i like rock music
i like acoustic music i like folk music
um i like lo-fi music
i like i like a bunch of things i like a
bunch of things
play some k-pop i don't listen to k
don't listen to k-pop
oh my gosh i wouldn't even know i don't
even know what spooky scary skeletons is
i only know it from the
it's like from tick tock isn't it like
spooky scary skeletons
oh what are you doing kieran you said up
here somewhere stop motion
intro to animation can't wait to make
and move some balls and stick men
oh that's so cool that's so fun
yeah i know the lights the lights don't
work i'm sorry i'm going to try and fix
them for for next time sorry about that
people
they have been working because they
um i've got them working on
on uh
when someone follows me and stuff anyway
yep it must have been because i had an
update of the software that i use and
maybe it's
wiped all of my codes i don't know what
it is but it's definitely done something
spooky scary skeletons
yeah see
it's got all the chat commands here i
don't know why it's not working
i don't know but it'll work if someone
follows
or i think
like super chats or something
we'll find out as the stream goes on
hey michael
[Music]
do you like 80s music i i guess it
depends on what kind because i can't say
i like every single apt's music
like i listen to like nirvana that's 80s
right
twitch gang
twitch game i'm glad you say that if i
happen i have been contemplating
just moving over to twitch full-time to
be honest and then re-uploading to
youtube
um
that's probably gonna happen in the
future
just because it'll be easy for me and i
feel like i'm missing out on all the
cool functions of twitch because i
restream because if you restream and you
stream on two platforms
you are unable to get um all the cool
things that come with being a twitch
affiliate uh and that comes with all the
the community things and as well of
obviously money like money is a part of
it as well i don't get any of that now
so
it probably would be a good move to just
stream on twitch and then re-upload the
videos afterwards so i'm probably going
to be doing that but we'll see won't be
till next year anyway
are you anyone in specific or just yaz
which i'm just yeah which but i did
think that this dress had some like um
what's she called
what is she called
jesus christ what is she called
uh
[Music]
adam's family morticia morticia vibes i
think it's just because it's long and
black but it's like morticia vibes um so
i was like oh my tissue but she doesn't
wear a cloak so i just i just bought
this clothes because i just thought it
would look really cool
um so yeah i just think yeah which
basically but i do think that the uh the
dress has got more tissue vibes
i do love the adams family
hocus pocus vibes yes with this with
this cloak i'm definitely hocus pocus
vibes
which is funny you should say that
actually because i was learning a song
from hocus pocus
um
which i will sing for you in a bit
wait what time is my break 4 45 okay
that's good if we've got ages good
i was like oh it's not 3 45 is it no i
think i've timed this quite well we have
a couple of hours of just chatting
singing and then a couple of hours of
photo frame and then a couple of hours
of games with friends so
i think it's good oh what did you send
me black hearts michael castillo
hey chanu
boo oh my gosh hey vitamin say tj
how are you doing geez long time no see
oh for anyone who remembers me back in
uni days i used to live with vitamins
and two others referral and nina
i'm sure some of you probably remember i
know jamie you you know
but yeah
oh glass on the past i miss you i miss
all of you
it's been so long you need to come visit
after covid well i guess kobe's like
lessening now isn't it just it's just so
crazy these past few weeks where's years
have just been mental
are you doing anything for halloween
vitamins
i remember the jagman uni series
yeah
such wholesome innocent days so many
good characters yeah i felt like i was
so much more sociable back then i'm
doing all right just stopping by for
some spoopy spoops spookies poofy times
thanks betterments
and we're playing fatal frame later i'm
sure you'll probably be gone by then but
yeah that's gonna be scary although it's
a shame because apparently they're not
they're not they haven't remade the
really good ones they've remade the one
that was on the wii u which is i think
the third one i know when rick's life
comes they can tell us um
but yeah it's not as scary but
everyone's saying please buy this fatal
frame remake because if it does good if
it sounds good they might remake the
first couple as well and that would be
really cool and fun to play i have been
keeping an eye out for the games though
because i do have a ps2 um so hopefully
i could just use that because i have my
capture card that you lovely people have
to buy me
and i will say it again we are raising
money for charity so
if anyone wants to um donate
to
the woman's trust
then you can help us reach our goal
and uh yeah that was really cool
if if you want to if you want to if you
want to of course
okay
time for another song yeah let's do it
[Music]
let's do this one
it's been a while
tell you what i'm gonna just turn down
my microphone i'm worried i'm gonna like
blow out your ears i mean i do that a
lot anyway
you know just stinky
[Music]
i feel
i've got to
run away i've got to
get away
from the pain you're driving to
[Music]
i'll give you all a girl can't give you
take my tears and that's not nearly all
day
[Music]
you don't really want any love for
i'm sorry i don't play that
[Music]
i'll give you all a girl can give you
take my tears and that's not nearly home
don't touch
[Music]
touch your baby
i'll never stop loving singing that song
it's just such such such a good song
saying
it's so good
montage hello welcome
we got a just giving thingy yay let me
let me just see who it was and say thank
you
um
welcome mantas you look amazing thank
you check this out
it's like i'm going to an actual
halloween party
um ah
okay
cast a spell
battle
trouble with toil and
trouble
[Music]
cast the spell on
the chat
and there's double
[Music]
there you go
i don't know what that spell's gonna do
but tomorrow if you have stubble you're
gonna wake up and something's gonna
happen to it if you don't have stubble
you'll wake up and you will have stubble
you're welcome
um
mocap for the next harry potter game
oh man you know what i know some people
that are working on the next harry
potter game as in like the open world
one and i'm so jealous
but it's gonna be it's gonna be good
although i don't know i'm so i'm so torn
between my love for harry potter and
jacob well not my love for jk rowling
that's my my torn that my love for harry
potter but my disdain for jk rowling
values and uh the things that she said
so i'm just like ah
do i but then you know because i know
people who are working on the game i'm
just like
i want to do it to support them but then
ah i don't know
neil
thank you so much for your donation
let me have a look at the donation page
you don't really want any love for me
to make a thing survive
you need someone to hold you
tight
and
you think love is to play
baby
i'm sorry i don't
play
that way
once i went from you i'm just getting it
so you can see the um
just giving page as well
because i'm nice like that
she says
uh okay
so
[Music]
we have had four supporters already yeah
i won thanks me who else have we got um
is the live stream not working on this
oh jesus christ so many things not
working today
you're supposed to be working what's
wrong with you
um
where can i see all the supporters
there
neil thank you so much neil jesus christ
thank you so much neil i didn't realize
how much you'd actually given a hundred
pounds plus 25 gift aid
damn
thank you thank you thank you thank you
thank you so much
and if 196 thank you so much as well and
johnny sid thank you thank you donation
for a great cause and also so yes which
doesn't put a curse on us and neil says
great charity keep up the good work love
your videos oh thank you so much
everybody
that is i can't believe that i didn't
actually look at how much was raised so
we've already raised
like 160 pounds
oh that's amazing we're already nearly
half way that's so good thank you thank
you thank you i really really appreciate
that that's amazing
and i will keep we'll keep checking on
that um
as we continue throughout the day we
might have to push the goal back this
happens every single time i do a charity
stream you guys are so wonderful or you
people are so wonderful i'm trying to
stop saying you guys
um
yeah because i did my goal today of like
400 because i remember the last few
times i've been doing things like this i
put a goal of like 100 or 200 and we
always surpassed that so i was like okay
let's put 400 and we'll see
but look at that
already halfway there that's amazing
thank you so much that's so cool
oh my gosh why am i so burpy i'm so
sorry it's the beginning of the day and
i've just had my coffee
yum yum
all for a good cause yes ip
fatal frame ps2 game well clay this time
this time you were speaking you'd be
speaking truths because i will be
playing that yes at uh what time am i
playing that five o'clock
so
in about
about an hour and a half ish
i will be playing them
when are you not brave shut up
don't call me out like that
what do you mean
yeah i know i am quite prepared
um
beginning of the day yeah i know i'm
just making excuses
hey
hey elvis oh
geezer
thanks for coming
hello probably manix
i grew up with harry potter and loved it
to bits but uh i don't like jk anymore
yeah
it's such a it's such an
ugh
it just
yeah
because a lot of us grew up with it as
kids and it was like one of the first
book franchise that we fell in love with
how can i donate oh thanks thank you
elvis um the donation is here i'll just
put it in the chat uh donate here
looking forward to the new birthing job
i could fit like so many nice vocals and
then just have like a burping interlude
or something
burping breaths
no worries if you can't stay thanks for
popping in anyway though i appreciate it
especially when recording vocals ah no i
do i do especially when it's
high-pitched vocals and it's very airy
and breathy it's like my breath just
gets trapped in my in my throat i just
need to grab it all out
he hasn't been stirred simply
prep the alphabet i see i can't barf on
commands i don't know how people do that
i think if i well i have tried that and
yeah i feel like i'm going to be sick so
i can't i can't do it i can't do it
that sounds like a charity goal
oh
[Music]
yeah i see i don't do things like that
do i i'm not i'm not i'm never like oh
we reach the if we reach this
number i'll shave my head
because i don't want to i don't want to
do something like that what can i do if
we reach this number i'll burp
but you've already heard that before
i'll burp a song but i can't burp on
command so i'm just going to puke a puke
on camera
maybe you would like that you probably
would
but i i would not like that
i'm really excited for tonight because
we're going to play phasmaphobia and
it's had so many updates and i thought i
was going to play that game again
because i i was
too brave for it now
basically just too brave for it but no i
think it's gonna i think it's gonna be
scary and i'm excited i was gonna play
um
back for blood as well we'll see how
much time we've got left i've been
playing back for blood
it's fun but it's just it's just you
know
left for dead really with cards that i
don't completely understand the card
system yet because i've like made decks
and then i can't use them in the
campaign
because i'm still stuck with my the one
i initially started with so i don't
understand that and then i think i ran
into a bug where i couldn't pick up any
throwables
and i was like
i want pipe bomb
why it just wouldn't let me have
anything in my third
like my three key inventory slot so i
was like
yay
but
just imagining the round face the round
round face of what
bald man x are you talking about me
shaving my head
you know what i have i was told once a
while ago a long time ago that i would
look good bold
i don't know
about this
my hair is such a massive part of like
who i am
even this even with my hair up i'm just
like i hate it i hate it because also a
digger used to get bullied about the
size of my forehead
so
much better
much better i don't really ever have my
hair up
see if the forehead is it really
yeah maybe it's just that bad i don't
know
maybe it's just because no one ever sees
it so when they do they're like whoa it
exists jesus christ but it probably is
just massive gigantic i mean i am like
an intelligent person so
what can i say
your mane is really good thank you i've
been working on this maine for ages i
was thinking of uh this is gonna
come across that's really like oh my
gosh you're just a bit big but i was
thinking of maybe putting up like before
and after pictures you know how people
do like with like diets and stuff
because
hair is such a
thing to try and take care of and i've
actually been working very hard for
years now to like get my hair in really
good condition because it wasn't in very
good condition about
eight years ago my hair was not in very
good condition you can see pictures of
it like if you scroll way back on my
instagram and it looks completely
different it's a lot straighter it's a
lot more rat taily it looks a lot
thinner as well and that's because i
used to straighten it i used to spend
like an hour straightening it when i was
16 to be like dead straight i just
wanted straight hair
um and it killed my hair basically so
it's been taking me years to get it back
to kind of alive
which is nice
but yeah it takes a lot of dedication
and stuff because you can't use heat
products um
you got to make sure that it's
conditioned well that it's that it's
kept up at night
that
you use the right products the right
hair products it's quite expensive
because you don't want to use anything
with any parabens or sulfates in it
it's it's
it's something but the results are great
so you just keep doing it but yeah heat
will
damage your hair and to be fair my dad
did tell me this when i was younger
because i burnt my face once with the
hair straighteners burnt to my face it
they fell and i caught them and i like
literally seared my face it was like a
line down here and he was like this is
why i don't understand why girls use
hair straighteners and now it's their
own prerogative and i think hair
straighteners they they save so much
time
especially back then when the fashion
was to have straight hair obviously hair
straps are great but no i fried my hair
and it's taken me years to get it back
so anyway enough of the hair vance um
hi from earth hiya rope
hi from venus
oh [__]
look at this
i think uh i think elvis
made a donation let's have a little look
let's see what we can see
well someone who donated i know they're
dead
hmm
let me log in
i'm looking at it like a person
when are we tainted
as well
thank you so much for 40 pounds elvis
that's so nice of you witchy vibes
and a 10 pound gift aid
and thank you so much mantas a pizza
money oh no
thank you for giving us your pizza money
for today
that's very generous of you i hope you
find something equally as tasty as a
pizza to eat today
that's so nice of you
i'll bless you
look at you're all coming in today
oh
i love you i miss you how are you
she's a busy woman oh i miss you so much
you are dreaming about you like all the
time
i'm dreaming about you and nina and tj
like all the time
whilst in reality you are a witch
we need to go
to germany next year referral
thank you so much for the super chat
what are you sending me
a annalisa vento sula luna feat rko me
official video what
did you give me a link
it's actually just telling me the uh see
the lights work for this
well thank you very much
i don't understand but thank you very
much
oh
i love i miss you
need to come and see you
next next year i've made it like
something for myself i need to be more
sociable i have been so unsociable the
last couple of years it's been horrible
i mean obviously because of kovid but i
need to integrate back into society i
need to see friends again so
you obviously refaro and tj and nina are
like way up there on the list need to
get out and go see people
people that i love
play song little lady okay okay yeah
yeah yeah
i will
um okay let me play this one i haven't
played it in a while
but it's a spooky one well it's not
spooky but it's halloweeny so um we'll
see how it goes i'm sure some of you
will know so you can sing along so if i
mess that up then if you're singing you
won't you won't know this
so it's fine
thank you so i can't believe we're over
halfway already i'm gonna have to adjust
this goal
[Music]
i sense there's something in
the wind
that feels like tragedies
at hand
and though
i'd like to stand by him
can't shake this feeling
that i have
the worst is just around the
bend
and does he knows
my
feelings for him
and will he see
how much
he means to me
i think it's not to
be
what will become of my different
why will his actions lead us then
and
though
i'd like to join the crowd
in their
enthusiastic cloud
[Music]
try as i be
it doesn't love
[Music]
no i think not
it's never to become
[Music]
another
one
[Music]
it's sally's song
cute
hello iris on twitch who are you
is uh
and what does iris stand for
oh
that's so cute
yes we need to come to berlin
i've been looking at i've been looking
at um prices we'll see we'll see we'll
see
um
i've missed singing for you vitamins and
refaro and nina
cuties
let's go
you know what we can we can switch to
the guitar now and i can play you a
little song
that basically i wrote but it was a poem
uh and then the wonderful jamie has i i
kind of did like a really crappy demo
and then sent it off to jamie and he's
been turning into something
quite weird which which is good like
but i'll play you it from a standard
um guitar
version
and see what you think
i'm having way too much fun in this
[Music]
oh jesus oh no
are you okay
well i'm gonna have to take this cloak
off at some point because it's getting
caught on absolutely everything
it's just a pain how do witches do it i
don't know i guess they have magic
so their cloaks just probably come out
the way of anything that it's gonna get
stuck to
okay
[Music]
you take one
step
it
follows through
shadow
looping over
[Music]
a dark embrace with a numbing touch
trickles down your thigh
a poisonous tongue latching to your
skull
a constant stream of light
[Music]
you
take one step
it follows
[Music]
oh
to
suffocate your mind
hands caress into a deeper depth
weight on your shoulders weight
on your spine
you
[Music]
all you say
one second
unwavering your eyes control your view
what a mess of limbs hold you
a gay pink mouth falls below your head
somewhere deep inside
an echo set
i am your safety now
[Music]
can't you
your see
and illness that will
never set you free
sickness others don't deserve
so you've just
leave them
[Music]
stay
with
me
[Music]
i don't know how to end it
something like that but yeah it's in the
works um i
i don't know if it's too boring like on
a guitar like that but
it's cool because it was like a poem
first and then it's going to turn into
something and you'll hear it eventually
i might even save it till next halloween
to be honest but
i'm quite happy with the way that it's
going oh we got some some sparkly lights
up here what's happening
i'm missing things what's happening
oh thank you so much gaming with malachi
and welcome happy halloween to you too
do the mesh master match
simple chords but i like the rhythm
thank you yeah it is simple chords it
was like
i just
so like i've been learning the guitar
obviously for a while now and then i
have not been really like making any new
songs i think part of the reason is i
put too much pressure on myself now to
like make songs better than the last so
like more complex and like
new chords or like new like
progressions or like finger plucking or
whatever and i think that takes away
from the fun of like actually just just
writing a song you know what i mean like
i remember when i used to write loads on
the ukulele and i was never thinking oh
it needs to be like better and you know
different and whatever i was just
writing from the heart um so
yeah i just picked up the guitar found
that little progression and i was like
that could work with the poem that i
wrote and i would love that poem to be
turned into something so
and we're here now that's how we got
there
whoa
whoa indeed
game with malachi so generous of you
thank you so much
work in progress yeah
it's definitely a work in progress but i
think the
the poem
uh i wrote a while ago and i think it
means well no i know it means quite a
lot to me and i think hopefully um it's
written in a way where i think it could
be quite a cool
like cinematic kind of piece i don't
know that's how i see it anyway that's
why i wrote it as well
to be kind of like something that you
can envision in your head
uh so yeah
yeah that's very true i think a lot of
songs now actually like especially these
like tick tock famous songs i listen to
them and they're so simple so simple but
i think that's why they're so catchy and
also why it's like really nice to learn
and sing
when you're learning guitar as well so i
don't think
a song needs to be like overly
complicated to be great i mean there are
really complicated songs that are
amazing and you know
i like rock music and um i wish i could
play half of the songs but i can't
because uh yeah a lot of like rock
musicians are [__] talented
and i'm naturally not that talented on
the guitar so
simplicity is beauty
it is very you thanks referral
not everything has to be complex yeah
yeah
ah so i can't believe we're already
over halfway in our goal and we're we've
only been streaming for like
how long were you streaming for i don't
know like an hour or something
so that's crazy
it's four o'clock now we've got 45
minutes and then i'm going to take a
little break
and uh
and then come back and play fatal frame
so we've we've got a lot planned today a
lot planned today people
it's gonna be a good day
have you ever gotten a voice or singing
coach
um so when i was really young
i used to be in the theater
and i used to get coached on singing
then that was very young like 12 or
something
um i was baby gym hello everybody my
name's june what's
yours weird
and uh yeah i remember ah i remember
being in primary school which is like
little little school and my music
teacher told my mom like i had potential
in singing thank you so much for
following black bitcoin billionaire and
basically she said that my mom should
like send me to like this singing school
um but my mom didn't have the money so i
like we never did no
no
i doing anything spooky tonight no
unfortunately not
i like so i've just moved to brighton
but i still have like no friends here so
and like obviously kobe has made it
pretty difficult so i'm just doing the
stream
and then who knows i might go to the pub
we'll see
um
but
it doesn't really matter it would be
nice to do something but maybe next year
maybe next year
but this is my thing because i was like
i want to do something spooky but i
don't really know how or where to go and
like you know i don't really have like
many people to deal with so i was like
well i'll just stream
because then i'm sure there's a lot of
other people on my boat as well who
don't really have anything to do because
i know kobe's lessened but i know it's
still it's still a thing and that means
that a lot of stuff still isn't back to
normal and you know back open properly
and stuff so i thought well if i hold
something like this then we can all get
together and at least
we'll all have plans
what are you doing refaro
you're not doing anything either
streaming is a good plan too yeah
yes and it's cheaper
so
yes
mr phone to be your friend there oh yes
please do please please do
it's actually next we went swimming in
the summer
although
some of the places to swim are actually
a big grimy
my mom came to visit and we went
swimming and we were like we could smell
sewage and then i realized like there
was actually a sewage pipe near like the
bottom of brighton and that's why we
went swimming so yeah bad call maybe go
swimming on the opposite end of brighton
but nah it's actually really nice
oh yeah spending halloween with us so
sweet
yes
yes yes
oh yeah jamie yeah of course you would
know about that because you're nearby as
well yeah so at the moment the well
luckily the big men
are back now jamie but for the last few
weeks ben men have been on strike and uh
yeah
garbages have been piling up all over
brighton and i walk in to brighton and
it's just so smelly everywhere it's just
so smelly
so smell it
swimming in sewage sounds like a
halloween plan
nice also
oh my gosh right of course you know
because we went to brighton for my
birthday like ages ago i'm gonna say
because like there's just pebbles
everywhere and i hate things from my
feet so i go swimming but then i'm also
just like crying
because i hate things touching my feet
so it's uh it's fun but it's also a
journey and
it's an adventure
playing phasmaphobia with friends is the
same as a halloween party
that's so true yeah
i'm so excited to see what weird updates
they have for phasma
phobia piggy back right at 5pm
and then weren't you just watching some
people like holding a seagull as well
brian is full of really strange people
actually it's it's really fun but
this is so many strange like there's um
someone around my area where every night
at like midnight you hear this radio
like a static radio and it sounds super
eerie super scary kind of like your
silent hill but with actual talking
coming from the radio and i found out
it's this old dude who walks his dog at
like midnight every night and he doesn't
listen to
i guess he doesn't have a phone or i
don't know but he listens to this carry
around radio and he just brings it
around with him so you just like see him
coming through the darkness with this
little radio and you hear like talking
you hear the radio before you see him
and it's really freaking scary
uh but yeah it's it's an interesting
idea for like a a video game horror
like a video game enemy or something
like perhaps it's like slant hillway if
you get close you can hear the static
but it's from them and then maybe if
there's something you need to hear to
help you with a puzzle or whatever you
need to get close enough to them to hear
what they're saying through the radio
but not too close that they see you and
then kill you that could be a really
scary mechanic
that would be really cool actually
what chad
he's definitely not a chad he's
definitely not a chad
ah i really want to go thought park for
halloween yes me too mantas me too
yeah i want to go i want to get thought
back because they have all their weird
like scare things don't they i remember
for ages i wanted to be one of like a
zombie there maybe i'll try and be a
zombie there next year because that'd be
fun and then you could go there next
year and then i'll be a zombie there and
i'll just like
scare ya that'll be fun
white noise is creepy white noise is
creepy um
have you been watching um buzzfeed have
been doing more uh
getting ghost what are they calling like
spooky boys you know they go and look
for ghosts in spooky haunted places uh
they've been doing more of those and the
spirit box every time i'm just like i
could not
it's so creepy and then they hear
little segmented sentences and i know it
could just be all a coincidence but i'm
just like i could not
i don't know how they'd do it
yeah terrifying kids as a zombie is a
mood
and adults
terrify everyone
whoa mantas you listen to white noise
when you're studying i mean each to
their own but that's kind of creepy
oh no okay thanks for coming rafaro
i love you
oh i hope we see each other soon
we'll make it happen next year next year
you know what helps me sleep and it's
weird because it's really scary it's a
whale noise like whale song
ah
love you
cute
i use white noise when i sleep okay so
apparently it is a thing people listen
to white noise to
to be put to sleep and to study and
stuff fair enough fair enough
big blue whale
i just love whales they sound so scary i
actually wrote something about a whale
where did i write about the whale
um
i wrote something about a whale
and i really liked it it was in my
creative writing course
it was like
um
whale sorry
i'm getting distracted now where's the
thing that i wrote about the whale the
thing the thing on the whale
mhm
this is a random stuff here i've got so
much random crap
in my does anyone use google keep i use
google keep and i've just got so much
random crap
in it
no
here i am doing nothing just scrolling
no freaking way who
is that is that
what
is that real
we need to we need to check this out
what is that how did that
what is that
um
no
what
oh my gosh
how is that is that a bug
i'm so confused
i'm on it now
uh
who in the world
how did that happen
[Music]
let me refresh again
it's gotta just have not
jesus bloody christ it is as well first
of all thank you michael because i don't
think i've said thank you to yet a small
dedication to you yasmin and to you emma
that's cute
and uh
anonymous
like you're not even gonna say who you
are you're just anonymous
how very day
no thank you so much 170 pounds jesus
christ plus a 42.50 gift aid did you do
that on purpose because that's really
generous
oh my gosh thank you so much i can't
believe we've already reached our goal
oh thank you so much that means so much
honestly thank you
like
it's horrific the amount of women that
get affected by domestic abuse and how
often that happens and just the fact
that we're helping
hopefully helping um them get some
some help and like a form of escape and
um
healing after the fact as well because
it can take years and years and years to
heal from domestic
abuse um
yeah it's just amazing thank you so much
i i really can't i can't believe that um
okay what do we do now do we
do we move the goal do we move the goal
i guess we'll have to move the goal what
do we do do we just say we reached our
goal and that's it we just carry on now
you've got to we've got to move it right
what do you think
anan please charitable ana
oh my gosh
i can't believe that
someone get the shaver no
not my hair
what else can i do for you
[Music]
i don't know i don't know
okay
double it double it double it oh jesus
christ okay okay let's let's double it
let's double it ah this is mental
i am leave that oh thank you so much i
can't believe i don't even know who it
was that did that
double it that seems mental okay fine
now we're never going to reach 800.
okay
okay we're never going to reach it but
screw it
it's there now um
okay
800 halfway there baby
geez
absolutely crazy oh i'm berkey bernie
you're just slipping on in there
thinking no one would realize well i
realized i realized let me just get it
up so people can see
little little cheap cheeky 50 little
cheeky 50 from bergy here we go
thank you thank you
[Music]
well you're helping towards the 800 girl
now
so thank you very much this is mental
mental
now you have to really put up a reward
for the next goal what are you going to
do i don't know
what do you think i should do um
what do people do
i could dance i could i could do like a
witch dance but i've already done that
for you
before even getting to any sort of goal
one thousand you run down the street
with a broomstick i don't have a
broomstick but i could guess i could do
something oh jesus
how would you see that though you'd have
to still be attached to my computer
so i don't think that would work
another witchdoctor i could do a witch
dance that's easy
i could do a handstand for you
but i have to get changed i can't do
that in the chats
you use the guitars oh jesus i'd be too
scared
i'd break it i'm so clumsy have you seen
me
yeah i know kieran my community well
sorry not mine i don't owe any own
anything but this community is so lovely
so generous so wonderful
screaming yeah
need a gopro oh my gosh so you have like
broom vision oh jesus
oh you just see like up my nose and i'm
like
do a live stream wrong with the
broomstick
i'm just going on like a morning jog
with on my broomstick
sounds legit sounds good hey black
bitcoin billionaire i think i already
said that did you follow me on something
just now i think so something like that
i should probably play another song um
it's a a song that i was gonna play oh
yeah
okay so
i've been learning this one
so i might mess it up but we shall see
oh jesus
come on
come on this way this way
this way
it sounds like i turn into a caterpillar
right
cooking stream with a cauldron oh i
could teach you how to do my um
my steam well my my soup
uh it's very green
soup is actually so easy to make if you
have a blender you need a blender but
i've been loving stews recently no not
stews soups why do i keep saying stews
um
hey colin
welcome welcome
nice to catch you
nice for you to be here
baking stream not baking oh my gosh
you saw my news on my backyard attempt
right has everybody seen my baking
attempt if not
if not i need to show you right now
because it's atrocious it's a mess it's
very embarrassing
um
this is
my
baking let me just
get it up
there
that's my baking and that's also you
guys in the background and yeah that's
my baking i baked a cake
it was a cake
kind of
it was very crumbly
bit too i what i did was i put in um
like
a quarter too much of milk
and then i tried to try to fix it by
putting in uh the only flower that i had
because this is actually
most of this is just from a box as well
it wasn't even from scratch
i tried to fix it by putting in some
whole meal powered like like flour
that's actually for bread
um
yes i have to say i just failed
pretty much massive failure
on that cake right there and then i
shared it to twitter and i have some
really lovely people on twitter who are
like oh i would eat that it looks so
good i'm like please
you're really nice
but
no
no you wouldn't
uh
okay
was it good
i honestly don't think i think it was
good
i don't think it was good
[Music]
jamie says uh you did it that's nice
that's nice of you
but i i would not blame anyone if i put
that on their plate and they like
sneakily gave it to the dog or put it in
the bin because yeah i just i don't i
don't blame them
hey
prashial i did it i did see some of it
not all of it but i ate you know about a
quarter of it yeah
was it dense
no and it was just very crumbly and dry
it just wasn't very nice
new sub thank you very much bryshill
have a bit more pride of your work not
of this work i think we can all agree
there's some things that we're just not
very good at and that's okay
that's okay
and baking is definitely one of mine
with to the um very much disappointment
of my mother who loves baking she is a
baking connoisseur she her cakes are
amazing she's made cakes for like some
of our friends weddings and stuff she's
such a good baker i did not inherit that
i did not inherit that
i'm way too uh
way too impatient for it if i'm honest
with you but baking takes patience it
really does
okay
[Music]
come little children
i'll take thee away
into a land
of enchantments
[Music]
i'll show thee the way
children
[Music]
hush
now their children
i'll show thee the way
to weary of life
and desert
[Music]
quiet
come
little children
i'll take thee away
[Music]
little children the times come
don't
[Music]
hocus pocus
imagine a duet with this and a bass
voice for her offset that would be great
yeah
are there any other vocalists who do it
yet with hell yes i mean
jamie and i need to start getting back
together next year to be in the studio
um
and we sometimes play together which is
nice um there's no
males that i know that really that are
like artists very well that i trust
um but i would be obviously very open to
it um there are some people that have
asked me to do directs with them but
it's just very difficult because they'd
like to like meet up in person and a lot
of the people that i know that musicians
are from plymouth which is like my
original city um so i'm always like yeah
i can do it online
but i can't i can't come meet you
because i i don't live there but um i'm
hoping once i get more sociable and
that's like my whole goal is to be a bit
more sociable next year that maybe i can
go to open mic nights in brighton and
meet people and that would be nice
because i'm sure there's loads of
musicians in brighton uh so yeah that
would be really nice i i'd love to do
more duets with katie nicholas as well
it looks like she's got a new album or
something coming out soon so if you
don't know katie creative i think she's
going on youtube katie nicholas go and
check her out n-i-c-uh
h-l
nick colas
n-i-c-hey
nicholas she is a brilliant musician um
but yeah again she lives very far away i
guess it's just difficult to collab with
people when they live very very very far
away
oh
i looked down and michael michael just
messaged yeah we don't we don't see each
other we haven't seen each other in a
long time but we still message every now
and then
um
it's nice actually because i've like
moved around so much you know because
i've shared everything with you
but everyone that i've been close with i
do still stay into
intermittent contact with and yeah i've
met some wonderful wonderful people over
the years and it's really nice to still
call them my friends
but you know how it is once friends move
away and once you move away perhaps it's
just very difficult to keep in keep in
contact even though you do love and miss
them but you know the internet's just
not quite the same hence why next year
i'm making it my plan to just be a bit
more sociable be a bit less scared
because i'm terrified of like travel now
like
trains and stuff so i just need to get
over it and get back to living
i did take one step um i went to the
cinema
it was the first time i went somewhere
with a lot of people uh that was like
like you know no windows no doors um and
it was scary but it was good and i went
home and the next day i took my lateral
flow test and i was negative and it kind
of
made me realize okay i can be around
people obviously still be careful wear a
mask and wash my hands and everything
else but it doesn't mean that you're
going to
get get covered
people aren't scary and you know it's
okay to
talk to people and be around them so um
yeah take it step by step but definitely
going to see more people
use your car yeah well i can't use my
car for everywhere like if i do want to
go like
abroad or something i need to you know
get
better at being on like even trains and
also going into london i'm not going to
use my car to go i'm sorry i'm not going
to go i'll do that because
oh my gosh driving in london would be
the worst thing possible also have we
gotten more
have we gotten more we've got more
haven't we let's go and check this i
think we've got a more
uh
i'm pretty sure we've got
[Music]
more oh my gosh we have gotten more okay
let's let's
jeez
this is just
um
gaming with malachi
for a great cause
thank you very much
uh and wait let's have a look at all of
them
jesus okay yeah anonymous another
anonymous
why i want to know who you are so i can
say thank you but thank you anonymous if
you're still here thank you thank you
very much a hundred and thirty plus 32
pound fifty gifted which is amazing and
then a secret admirer hmm
every little helps is very true every
little does help so thank you so much
uh secret admirer anonymous and gaming
with malachi you're all
so generous and every little does help
ah so jeez i can't believe another
massive one from another person one
oh but thank you
look at that
we're already on 600. it's absolutely
crazy and there i was being like i can't
double 400 what do you mean double 400
that's mental but no we can we can do
that
sponsored by tesco what
i just i go out from time to time and
work at a grocery store still haven't
gotten covered just take care of
yourself and you'll be fine yes exactly
braggy yes i think it's um
for some people like me included
i don't mind talking about this but it's
definitely like
um turned into more of like a mental
thing
logically you know that if you're being
careful and whatever like
you're probably not going to get it and
double jabbed as well vaccine which i am
um then you're probably not going to get
it and if you are like you know
it wasn't your fault um and you just
have to deal with it then you isolate
make sure no one else gets it or phone
everyone just in case to let them know
um
but yeah it's like a mental thing now
it's like especially if you have some
sort of if you if you're not
very
naturally outgoing you're quite shy or
um
you know anxious anyway it's like an
added layer to that because you have
this like first initial thing of like
people are scary and now you have this
second added thing of like people are
scary and it is
a fact now because they could have this
disease so you know it's logical to be
scared of them so please do stay away
from them but that's just your brain
just being like horrible um
so yeah it's time to get time to well
for me anyway
small steps but i want to get back to
being
the old me well i was still not the most
you know out there and stuff but
i was so much better than i am now so i
can't wait but anyway hair chuffs
yeah exactly vaccine does help a lot
yeah it does
oh hell yeah
game with malachi even if we don't hit
800 it's still a major dub
major dub
wait was it you colin
colin are the anonymous things you
if it is you because you said it is i i
keep skipping over the name thingy he's
going to keep you in the dark thank you
so much colin really appreciate that
uh preschool do you know how to use
unity yes i haven't used it in a while i
used it during my university days that
was like two and a half years ago oh but
i did i guess i did use it since then
because i updated perfection um but yeah
yeah i know roughly how to use unity
um definitely not an expert on it i've
been using unreal a lot more lately
because i do that in my job role
calling for the win what are they
calling all right sorry
i'm like what did colin do i've just
literally said it yeah yeah
um
so much for me in my big head
yes sorry no don't apologize thank you
so much i really appreciate it really
appreciate it like honestly look at this
like like this big chunk is basically
you
this big chunk is basically what you
contributed so thank you so much really
appreciate that
colin what king me what king
[Music]
overcome the horribleness with your big
brain thanks ib i like
i like that uh
i like i like that thinking that
thinking that's there
okay we have 10 minutes until i've got
to take my break so what should we do
there should probably should be like one
more song or something right ah what do
i say what should i say what should i do
um um
and
um i could just
let's try and sing um a song on here
what a mine or
lonely day maybe one of mine
[Music]
everything you wanted
does it match up to what you saw
everything you needed
everything you work
so hard for
you might have your money but
go home
just
i can't
keep you warm see the stress and the
late night
late nights
you pushed away like your face
oh you deserve
more
[Music]
and everything i wanted
everything that burns
i can't believe it what
core
everything i needed
everything
for decor
i don't have much money but
i've got something worth
so much more
a future to grasp
if your hand will unclasp
[Music]
don't i deserve
more
[Music]
and everything we've wanted
i know it has changed from before
in our minds you plan
a vision of a life we can't afford
we'll waste all our money on
what you have shown will
mold
[Music]
i can't even concentrate and so we're
going to
[Music]
i'm sorry i'm so distracted right now by
this tell us we deserved
[Music]
with every ring called uh
did you see
as every moment
was it your choice you made
to
[Music]
judgment keeps us tame
to a place i dreams where
something far more
[Music]
and
who
who how who how we're gonna have to up
the card again
what oh my gosh thank you so much
there's still two more parts of the
stream left
to go
um let's have a look let's have a look
let's have a look look look look look
let's have a look let's have a look
[Music]
um
refresh please
colin is that you again is that is that
you again colin
colin is he is this you again
what
if it is you again and these wait both
of these both of these
there's a 15 and there's 200 no they
must they must be two different people
because they're in two different
currencies as well
if this is you again jeez thank you are
you sure like
thank you so much but are you sure thank
you thank you
and 15 from another anonymous who are
these people are you gonna out
yourselves are you gonna out yourselves
hey john loads of moneys
[Music]
half of each eyebrow
i remember you my first contact with
your channel was the charity stream
playing resident evil 7 man of constant
sorrow yes i remember because i was like
oh that's a cool name
oh wait now you're looking at yourself
let me come back
uh
it's uh
it's n a colin it's gotta be colin colin
oh colin are you sure where are you
mian's got the dolls
and who else who else
anyone want to own up to being anonymous
here right now right here right now
right here
well we're gonna have to up the uh
up the goal again what should we up it
to a thousand
is jeff bezos in chat
if so jeff please send me to space
i'll sing for you instead
double it double it that's too much
um let's see one thousand
two hundred one thousand two hundred
i need to go to the toilet okay we've
got we've got two minutes to go and i
need to go toilet anyway so this is a
good way to end it
right
we're going to up the goal to 1000
uh
just a thousand yeah we're gonna up the
goal to a thousand
and uh we'll see because um i think this
you know this time we've been chatting
you know there's been a lot of time to
donate and then next time when i come
back in literally 15 minutes we're gonna
be playing fatal frame so people are
gonna be busy watching me scream
hopefully if all goes well so let's up
this
uh but thank you so much like
the generosity here is plenty
overwhelming i
i can't believe it
but yeah thank you just thank you just
thank you
that's all i can say is thank you
okay i'm gonna go now i'll see you in 15
minutes because don't forget um this is
the
this is the
the schedule that we have today
so it's
three to four forty five which is now
singing and chan and then we got five
till seven thirty fatal frame and then
we got eight till ten which is games
with friends so i will see you in 15
minutes where i'm gonna come back and we
are gonna play fatal frame so
chat to you later i'll see you in 15
minutes and bye everybody
goodbye
bye
yeah
so
welcome back everybody
[Music]
we are gonna now be playing some facial
frame
uh thank you so much i have to point out
again as usual everyone who has donated
uh we are at
822 pounds so far which is absolutely
bloody incredible so the
goal's gone up twice and right now it's
a thousand pounds
uh i think that's the most we've raised
for anything
uh so thank you thank you very very much
and yeah
let's get ready to play some spooky
fatal frame
um fingers crossed everything will be
okay with this game i know it's been a
little bit difficult for some people to
play
um
so we shall see
there were some
um
v-sync issues that i hopefully have
sorted
so we'll just see how this goes
hey becca
hey plushie you got
hey man
hey sidna
hey air hey kieran thanks everyone for
sticking around
oh please
when the mouse is just left on the game
screen you're like no
or if you're like watching netflix and
your mouse is still on the screen i hate
that okay set the brightness so you can
see the ghost's face i
oh
i didn't even realize there was a ghost
face there guys can you see can you see
the ghost's it's very
it's it's very um
hidden but i think about that maybe
there because i want you to be able to
see it as well
okay you still owe us one unit of guitar
broom i can do it around the bedroom if
you want um let's let's do it
but by the end of the stream okay i i
will do the guitar broom remind me
michael if you're at the end of the
stream
or anyone who is at the end of the
stream remind me we'll finish the stream
with um
me flying around my bedroom but which
would be very
very fun
um the game's already spooked yeah yeah
but it's freaky i literally didn't
realize it was a ghost girl just right
there can you see her as long as we can
all see her i think you can
okay
we'll leave like that because i don't
want it to be too
bright let's turn down my lights
oh that's much better okay
i can see the game better now
this work is fiction
no actual people
[Music]
as usual let me know audio if you want
me to turn the game up me down whatever
you want i got your boot
mew
hinasaki
spirited away lava movie
in the vicinity of mount hikami people
have been mysteriously disappearing with
that choice one such girl is miu
hanasaki she awakens to find herself in
an
in an old half-flooded building
why was she in mount hikami anyway
[Music]
oh kiki's streaming service that's so
cute
it be hair
or water
it's both
the water is cold where am i
oh there's dead people in the water
[Music]
ugh
wait what
right i start right here oh great
with the titty ghosts
we have to get out of here too many
titty goes
hello titty ghosts
why are their boobs so big and round and
bouncy let's go
i'm sorry i subtracted fried you
but i wasn't the one who contacted you
let's go
am i going to i am going toward that
door right now i'm going towards that
door [__] me
oh [__]
why doesn't she run what's wrong with
her
oh like this okay
i was just walking the whole entire time
i didn't know you could run i have to
find a way out of here
[Music]
look it's a source of power i must drain
from it
she is really wet she sounds like a slug
right now
there's light at the end of the corridor
but maybe there's a way out
they're chasing after me i have to get
out
what's this room oh i can't go into it
fine
they're not doorknobs
okay so a bunch of people died there
like
what was that was it water was that oil
because you can't really tell
lt to point the camera straight ahead
yes
water
[Music]
what am i supposed to do now
oh [__] [__]
oh okay i can go this way
[Music]
that's a lot of cutscenes isn't there
uh
where's my hand going
[Music]
okay
well that was uh interesting i didn't
expect to be thrown right in
the thick of it but there there we go
there we are
no one could hear the cries for help as
she something
the mountain is where the events of the
story take place
we follow the fates of three people
yuri ren and me
it's a terrifying tale of the
supernatural
[Music]
black water
okay so that was just like an
introduction to how
many people are dying there
and in what manner i guess and now
we're following the actual
people
first drop a vanishing trace yuri
kazu kata
so sorry if i'm butchering any names by
the way
among the residents of the villages at
the foot of mount hikami a certain
unique ability has been passed through
the ages this ability known as shadow
reading enables the user to view the
shadow or trace of someone lost in
inexplicable
inexplicable circumstances
this is not unlike the psychometry
practice elsewhere
yuri kozukata accompanies his hisoka
kurozawa a woman who possesses the
shadow reading ability to an abandoned
inn on mount hikami
sensing yuri could in time become
talented at shadow reading
hisoka takes her along on the assignment
okay so she's got like a padawan
i thought that i'd be scared of death
but i can't even cry
i am alone
in the end
what we're looking for should be in here
this is an excellent chance for you to
take the lead
here take this oh
fancy fans fans photography
this is a place love their outfits it
will let you see the unseen
including the clues that will help you
find what we're here for
this is your opportunity your first case
oh sorry blood curse is a great game
michael
terrifying absolutely terrifying i'm
sure you'll do well
and difficult as hell let's start with a
little practice
it works exactly like a normal camera
give it a try just hold up the camera
okay
stay tuned
nice shoes
oh my gosh
the camera obscura photographs the
netherworld a whole other world separate
from our own can i zoom like is there a
zoomie
that world that we see through the lens
is not unlike the afterlife
make sure not to draw too much interest
from the things you see
beautiful darling
your neck looks a little weird but it's
so good or careful you might be drawn
into the netherworld yourself
why
all right okay
she wants to have this kind of photo
[Music]
to hold your capture area vertically
all right got you
you can lock onto a target
oh
never used to be like this
the mountain used to be revered as
sacred ground and it became a tourist
destination
now it's known as a place to commit
suicide oh that's not good
pretty
apparently only those kind of people
come to the mountain
yeah well we saw that we had a little
vision
my gosh you're so close
take this
it's a token it will help lead you to
what we're looking
for okay
now don't panic but be sure to stay on
your guard
go on and head inside
oh that's that's a really good map it'll
be uh extremely useful
you can press
okay
snap mode
what why if i got multiple just give me
one thing
i'm gonna get confused
snap mode
welcome to snap mode here you freely
position and manipulate characters and
ghosts in order to take without a
picture in camera operation mode you can
adjust the lens and frame whereas in
camera character operation mode you can
reposition characters once everything's
in place remove the menu display and get
schnappy snap snip snip oh i see what
you mean okay it's just this i don't
care about this yeah i don't want to go
into snap mode
i got an achievement
okay let's go
jesus why are there like why is her
skirt so short if she if she has one
tiny trip it's like the ghosts are going
to see
this had quite a shirt
[Music]
but it seems that this photo came from
somewhere around here and he wants us to
see whether we can find
[Music]
what's this
oh it's very wet in here
i'm gonna get my bare legs wet
what if what if there's like
disease in these waters
[Music]
there's a little hole in that wall there
can we get through the little hole
there's a heap of scrap road at the end
of the hallway the water must have
washed down here there's a hole in the
wall i can see the next room over it
looks like just as flooded
[Music]
oh well that's
crazy
[Music]
what is that is he wearing a tie
oh no that's just good
oh gosh
look you wanted to do this job lady
so let's do it
yep very spooky room
i don't know where this light is coming
from the big hole in the wall leading to
the pond the light from the sunset oh
that's really nice actually
illuminates the room with an eerie glow
spooky
let's go let's go let's wave through the
water
you really
can't believe we forgot our overalls
you're supposed to be my teacher yuri
wait
i can sense something why are your boobs
jiggling like this what is happening
okay um hold rit to find the trail
it's called a trace
a shadow of the past the token is
showing you the way
these traces can lead you to the right
path
okay
let's follow that shadow should we just
go in here first because you know you
never know what we're gonna find there's
a herb down here see
wrong game okay
[Music]
that joke is so old
hold rt and move ls
[Music]
oh i see
at least the trace like lightens up the
place a little bit
we will go down there late ah
oh jesus i did i would i would let i
didn't think about it
damn it
no there we go go down here
rt
i i our t
i had to hold not press
because it's uh you know it's a long
process to pick something up
an old dusty book has been left in the
hallway maybe somebody dropped it
mount hikami has a long
oh it's it's the downfall mountain kami
has long been considered holy ground for
centuries people have been drawn to many
sacred shrines and places of worship as
well as the natural features such as the
twilight peak and the pool of
purification which have themselves been
treated with great reference
yes yes tell me more the mount was also
popular with tourists and mountain
climates for the beauty of his abundant
clear waters and ancient mysterious
forests worshippers and hikers alike
used to find breasts in
ikea mana a hot spring resort near the
foot of the mountains
now the inn lies desolate devoid of
visitors the mountain never recovered
from a devastating landslide it suffered
many years ago the shrine road to the
summit was cut off and flow and the flow
of water through the mountain was
altered forever changing the landscape
new roads that were under construction
had to be abandoned the eq the ikero
manor was buried under a slew of rock
resulting in numerous fatalities
among those lost for the family of ikea
manor's proprietor official effectively
putting an end to the business monty
cami stays as the tourist destination
were no more instead the mountain gained
an entire
notoriety is a suicide spot perhaps
because it was traditionally a
destination to which the dying would
venture the mountains now a place for
those wishing to end their own lives by
extension it has also become a place for
thrill seekers interested in the occult
why
is there more trace thing
[Music]
yeah i could have guessed that it's the
only other place to go
and spooky spooky scared
oh good she's wearing big pants okay
that makes me feel better
or shorts maybe it's in this room
let's go in here
oh don't appear
try using the camera obscura
what
to look for a key or to use as a key
what do you mean when you look around
through the lens of the camera obscura
you may notice it reacting to objects
which are not normally visible lock on
and photograph them to expose places or
items they have a connection with find
the locations from the photographs and
you may discuss there as well
okay
what why is there like a weird
decapitated head on the wall
what is that what
why where is this
okay i guess we're gonna have to go back
and look
there's something in the photo yeah a
decapitated head
the light coming out of a closet and
there's a doll on top of the chest that
draws oh with a doll
this might be where the beard
to view the photograph again
here you go on ahead of me and look for
the key to the door i'll wait for you
here no
oh fine
i can do this
i can do this oh my [__] christine
hell
i was too late again
that was spooky though i didn't like
that
oh jeez
can we open this door
hello
spooky decapitated head doll i'm here
and i got my camera pew pew pew
good job ghosties here i come
excuse me
very so pick up
yeah i know where to go thank you
wait what was that like a hidden door
behind oh
i knew it i knew it i got you i got you
man looking at the key
[Music]
i hate her i hate her
i literally hate this doll so is there a
hidden
there's a step up here and it has
part of the floorboards i think it's a
display outpost
but then
didn't i just see
i don't like this
all right she closed it behind it right
okay let's go
everything opens so slowly i'm not used
to it don't like it don't like it i
think i see things all the time right
let's get back to uh
master
like resident evil and stuff is like so
fast-paced
i had to keep
somewhere in this room
take a look around
okey-dokey
i got you
come on
i know i know you're telling me to look
down try searching with the camera
obscura oh right yeah okay that's a good
idea it could be hidden invisible to the
naked eye
hold on oh jesus
i can't ready
the camera obscure reacts to items that
are normally hidden from the eyes of the
living you can bring those items back to
the world by taking by photographing the
place they were taken from with the
correct angle and position
focus on the alternate by
tilting the viewfinder with yellow
was that good was that bad
oh
is this it
okay
[Music]
this is what we came here for
this is how we do we shouldn't stay here
any longer than we need to
yeah i agree you're right
let's head back before it gets dark
yes okay
follow her don't just stand there in the
creepy room on your own freaking follow
her woman
wait for me i'm coming
oh jesus christ get out stop
stop jesus i'm so bad at this fast
camera movement
yuri searching for objects like we did
just now might be easy but searching for
people is much more difficult
whoa you move so fast how the hell your
tree allows you to see the psychic
imprint as a shadow
okay
never follow after the shadow of someone
who's been spirited away you might end
up seeing something you wish you hadn't
we haven't gone upstairs yet
no no
let's just follow you
where's your teacher she's just like
oh my gosh
uh ghost will try to attack you
okay
maybe taking more will exercise it for
good
photography weak points
damage
the rectangle center the screen is your
aerial attack you cannot take photos
[Music]
did i do it no i didn't
help me
okay
five or more times view taking a
photograph will knock back the ghost
the capture area will go red during the
short chance keep adjusting your
positions that you have at least five
targets including ghosts and spirit
fragments in view
it's a trigger shot a chance
okay i'll try i try
[Music]
it's like spirit orbs
[__] not another one
[Music]
when the capture area flashes red as a
ghost is attacking you can take a fatal
frame shot you need to capture the ghost
and then attack
apart from a knockback effect fatal
frame shots
trigger fatal time when you can take
photos in close succession without using
film basket field frame shots are very
useful when spirits are too close
[Music]
another one
which we're only has effects on ghosts
within a specific range goes too far
away we're not taking any damage the
bigger the target the damage
get closer to those more powerful shots
[Music]
quick quick quick
where
oh jesus there you are
i got a beach
where
[Music]
hit me hit me
hit me
[Music]
um
yeah it's very different i quite like it
though i mean it's totally different to
shooting a gun you have to get up close
and personal so it's quite scary
but it's a lot to kind of learn
thank you master for the cuddles i'm
sorry
i shouldn't have brought you here
i am
alone
oh
oh no
well i guess they said this was like a
religious place but maybe it was
you know some weird rituals happened
there or something
and now it's an interest for the occult
same again
um mr hojo
hasoka came by a little while ago
oh
he's so
what does she want
she found the photo book
she did
yeah here oh the book that we found in
the creepy place
ugh
oh it's the thing that he's been
dreaming about
while learning about shadow reading from
hisoka yuri used the ability to retrieve
an album of post-mortem photographs from
a ruined inn at mount hikami
the album was requested by a certain ren
hojo
[Music]
as ren awoke from a bad dream he found
himself tormented by uncertainty
was it really just a dream or was it a
suppressed childhood memory
this question has plagued him for some
time
yeah i can't see
oh it's because i was so slow at taking
all those black powers
damage
[Music]
the following additional content has
been added
oh i got costumes
awesome i got
a visor
how many points do i have
if punk says
cutesy goth oh there's a swimsuit
i don't have points oh
that was the other way around damn it
okay fine
[Music]
is it all gonna be a thousand
swimsuit why do i want them to be in
swimsuits i mean fair enough they were
just in a place filled with water maybe
a swimsuit would have been good then
but
come on what are you doing
why okay
[Music]
it's been several days since the
incident at the inn hisoka is out on a
case a young girl comes to the shop and
finds a borrowed yuri yuri is giving a
miss given a missing person case
something hisoka forbade
[Music]
stone revives you when you die
cleansing flames that remove redness and
taint
pure water that fully restores your
health
sure
[Music]
[Laughter]
i don't know
go with that
i was like a swimsuit of course a
swimsuit
second job mount hikami
a few days have passed since yuri's
introduction to the shadow reading of
the abandoned inn
since then circa has gone off somewhere
and hasn't returned yuri rory is for
herself but isn't sure how or where to
start searching as she sits waiting at
the antique shop a girl named
shows up
i'm very sorry um claiming to have
enlisted hisoka to help her find a
missing person
okay so that's where she went and she
hasn't come back from from that i guess
it was a very chill job isn't it
um
excuse me hello
i'm looking for hishoka kurosawa is she
here
oh i'm sorry but she stepped out
my name is fujihimino
i've been waiting for her to tell me if
if
she could help me find someone
i still haven't got a reply from her
you're looking for someone
she might have gone to the mountain
marakami
mount hikami
someone told me
that they saw my friend there
it's an infamous suicide spot isn't it
i don't know why haruka would go to a
place like that
and without even saying a word to me
don't worry as soon as hisoka gets back
i'll tell her no
that's fine i can't wait any longer
i'll go look for her myself
is she in like her nightgown
come back
silica left a few days ago and hasn't
been back maybe this is what she's been
working on
likely he said his room is upstairs
maybe she left some clues her
whereabouts yes
let's go looky looky looky looky watcher
let's go look i'm still nervous about
standing him up is it just me or do they
jiggle like i
can't
are they jiggling
i'm so nervous about studying about
myself because i've never been good at
handling customers oh me
uh i've only just learned how to make a
coffee and i never actually served a
customer yet oh my gosh this brings me
back i worked at a little cafe for a
while and making the coffee was
stressful like obviously a black coffee
americano that's fine but when it came
to the fancy cappuccinos and stuff
what was that check
these drawers seem
these drawers seem to be where the
shop's receipt and financial records are
kept i've not taken a proper look
through them yet
okay
i know we're supposed to go upstairs i'm
just going to have a little look at the
shop guys
i love all of these cameras so nice what
are we looking at here the road in front
of the shop leads to multi gaming it was
built for tourists but the only people
who use it now are the people who live
here
apparently michael was going to ask the
same question as me it's a tobacco tray
it looks more like an antique accessory
case than a functional
tray
yeah that's
interesting there's some very cool stuff
here what's in there the cupboard is
filled with cups that we don't use
anymore literally every time the camera
goes on here
they jiggle like
this is supposed to be a horror game
stop distracting me this is not scary
and
it's weird okay it's just weird i just
can't
uh what are we looking at the radio the
radio has been set out as decoration the
tune isn't working well so i've only
ever picked up white noise so why are we
playing it maybe we're like
hey maybe she's like mantas and she uses
it to like chill out and um study and
stuff
that must be it
the arrows
a little bit annoying because it tells
you immediately where to look straight
away and it's like okay
yeah
sometimes it's nice to just explore
yourself
uh a book about
mount hikami was lying on the bookshelf
it seems to be about the rumors
surrounding mount takami as a state as a
site of spiritual activity
suicidal mahikami how does a place
become famed for suicide as more people
die the place will gain a reputation and
people are drawn to these spots out of a
desire not to be alone in the end
interestingly these suicide spots are
rarely known as hot spots for spiritual
activity
this is what makes mount takami distinct
from the others it has a tradition of
suicide and has long been associated
with ghost sightings
then there are the so-called maidens of
blackwater it is said that if you are
found by one of those maidens they will
lead you to your death those caught in
the maiden's gaze never again leave the
mountain also the rumors go which is
what happened at the beginning of this
game
there were also tales of specters on
mount takami who really relived their
own deaths those who do not die in
accordance with the local practices
become cursed forced to relive their
final moments for return
[Applause]
many of the people who have been kept
from committing suicide on maoti kami
claimed to have seen a maiden or one of
these looping specters and felt a strong
compulsion to kill themselves
perhaps it is because of these stories
of maidens ghosts that the mountain
continues to be a popular spot for those
looking to take back life
yeah that sounds plausible
the deathly mountain a book about
mountain kami was lying on the bookshelf
it seems to be about a traditional
surrounding mountain
mountain army has long been feared to be
haunted in the past it was said but that
sleeping with one's feet facing the
mountain was taboo
and watching the sun set behind the
mountain too
was believed to invite fourth beings
from the netherlands
today the mountain is said to call to
those fascinated by death countless
rumors about a bound of people spirited
away to the accursed peak
they are said to venture to the mountain
alone leaving behind no trace of
themselves some say the bodies of those
who vanish can be found at the bottom of
the lake in the departed on the mountain
summit which is also what we saw in the
beginning since becoming a tourist
destination the prevalence of such
frightening tales did seem to diminish
for a while
even so despite its fleeting stat status
as a tourist hotspot montekami is yet to
shake its reputation as a cursed
mountain a place of death
today it's become a popular place at
which to commit suicide
okay
what do we know
anything on tv
[Music]
why are you opening things really creepy
like we're just in your shop
nothing creepy in here
is there
oh this place is bigger than i thought
it'd be
is that a bed where's the pillows
that can't be a bed
a pretty kimono hangs on a rack
okay
this is nothing adventurous
why the bills up
just check this
okay i don't think there's anything in
here
i mean i could use the camera but
i can't i can't use the camera
anything here
a small posit planting lily sits atop a
hello dresser isn't that lovely but i
can see that
can i open this
doors are just really heavy in this
world fair enough kieran that that could
be it this is ahsoka's room she really
likes the traditional japanese style
it's very nice oh hello hello it's a
working mirror oh i'm all jaggedy and
pixely
it's an old japanese style full length
mirror never i've never looked looking
into mirrors
because my titties bounce and it makes
me feel weak
nothing of interest nothing of interest
just a very heavy
draw
a folder reading lost items sits on the
desk looks like it's bound by string
these seem to be notes on hisoka's
shadow reading cases
clients missing item diary photo of the
deceased located by the diary client
seeks info on their late mother relates
to a deceased individual with like
caution
the caretaker of the deceased had burned
the diary at her request
okay so it's like all the things that
she's been doing
[Applause]
[Music]
found an old building
attempted to drag yuri toward the
netherworld should have got
gonna lie most for one year to stay away
from the mountain
uh album of person
reference material for a book about
traditional practice
bad location but minimal danger
anticipated
shadow reading is the ability to read
traces of the past not unlike the
ability
commonly known as psychometry by
following these choices it's possible to
find things that have gone missing or
which were no longer visible things that
are demonstrated blue there but for
reasons unknown all but invisible
things the only wish to be forgotten
things whose owners have passed away
things that no longer wish to be seen
things drawn part way into the
netherworld invisible within our own
such items can be called back to the
world of the living unlike these objects
however people who have been spirited
away must not be chased after lightly
in many such cases it has been taken
they have been taken by creatures of the
netherworld who linger nearby utmost
caution must always be applied
okay
a letter from
so that's the girl that came in
dear mrs kurosawa please find haruka she
went missing over a week ago you do
still take on missing person cases don't
you i've contacted the police but
they're no help they said she's probably
spirited away haruka wouldn't have gone
anywhere without telling me i'm certain
something bad has happened i can handle
my own grief but i can't stand the
thought of her suffering somewhere what
if she's waiting for me to find her i'm
already sick haruka is alive i know it
but something has to be done and quick
remember when you found that precious
picture of me in haruka i was so happy
to have it now i need to help once again
so that's the girl from the beginning it
must be she must have gone to mount
hakami to look for this girl
mount hakami
a place where many come to take their
lives
i'm positive that for you he must have
come here
for you he that's how he's here
oh yay
love being back here without my master
it's poopy
spoopy
want my chicken
there's a wood fence a wood post fence
along
the road by the pond
okay
this is where we were wasn't it
yeah
yeah that's where we were originally but
we're not going to go back there because
that was a horrible place
can we go here though
ah
okay
fine i know where the trail is
[Music]
a pool of purification
hello
the road has collapsed and the stone
stairs are cut off it must have been the
landslide the old world seems to carry
on up the edge cliff
what
where
up here
ah
okay
into the woods nothing spooky about the
words at night i don't know why i had to
come at night
i could have just come during the
daytime but i guess there's no time
water flowing from the rocks has pulled
here forming a small pond
let's go for a swim
no we're not on our swimsuit we didn't
have enough points for that
there's something on the ground
dramatic pickup
jesus [__] place
[Music]
i'm trying
press rt at the right moment to dodge it
okay fine
when's the right moment
oh it's not gonna happen again okay
oh cute
there's a way from the fall of
purification to the unfathomable forest
what a name
from the main menu open map wait what
oh
cute it's such a cute little map i want
to get up here
forbidden valley but it looks so nice on
the map
wait i'm here pool of purification
and shrine of dolls that's uh i don't
want to go there that we don't we don't
want to we don't want to go to shrine
itself um this is the town oh no no no
that's the hot spring so that's where we
were initially that's the way out
um
station
tunnel a new exit
a forest station
a female station
shrine of a female
this one a mountain path forbidden
and twilight peak okay
that's what we gotta get to
okay
[Music]
it's i like that it's kind of like our
little
guardian angel spirit just guiding us i
know i know it's not but
hello
i don't have a camera obscura what the
[__]
how
i guess i'll find it somewhere
but what's full of peaceful as it slows
down a lot of people probably come to
see this back from the mountains
uh
look at this shrine of power
we must draw from it
an old stone monument has been set in
the rocky hollow it's covered in lots so
i can't tell if there's anything written
on it it must have been a memorial for
those who lost their lives in this
landslide
is that the
all camera be careful
go sound
because
that
like the forbidden flame
they dry you remove the taint of black
water
oh okay
if you get drenched you'll become an
easy target from the little spirits
these purifying envelopes
how do i use them
purifying embers
okay
oh jesus
i'm saying that noise
are we going to see her again because is
this them being in a time loop of them
dying where's the right moment
ghost hands okay it didn't happen
pills made from the my raid of herbs
consuming their
there's nothing here oh
the road is buried in the earth and rock
grab some trees jut out from a monster
it must have collapsed a long time ago
backing up back in
hello
[Music]
i'm just a little girl
looking for a
friend
and teachers
that looks too easy
something's gonna happen
okay ghost hands are definitely gonna
happen here so get ready for it guys
because
it goes
[Music]
why is the music changed
the game told me not to get in the water
or is it just a certain type of water
oh i don't know this game is so
confusing let's go
the pool is being
ordered off by an old boarding break
there are stairs in the water that leads
to the waterfall was there supposed to
be a location
where's that thing in the water
[Music]
oh is the camera
geez i did not know that this camera was
waterproof
that's very impressive
yeah mantas you're probably right
they're gonna wait until i forgot about
the ghost hands and they're gonna come
back
[Music]
to use it equip it
to your camera obscura and press x
upgrade this allows you to equip and
take pictures from different lenses
juice
[Music]
oh [__]
oh no i forgot i've gotten all my
training i forgot my training
hey come come out and [__]
come on push him back no no no no no no
oh my god this is hard
oh my god
please come at me
come on
if you attack me then i can uh get you
better right i think i think that's how
this works oh
[Music]
he's alive geez
how do i get him
oh my gosh
come on
no
come on get in oh my god i can't get
them all in the [__] frame dude oh no
she's gonna kill me she's gonna kill me
she's gonna get me she's gonna kill me
come on
oh my god it's so hard to get them on
the frame oh jesus okay
that's
it oh thank you that took so long
okay hisoki is on the mountain too
but i should first focus on finding
yuhi first
okay
i agree
let's do that how do we do it like how
do i look at my house
and other things
uh
do i need anything purifying embers a
mirror stone
no sacred water
your health completely i think we're
okay i think we're okay it looks like
we're like halfway if what i think is my
health it's my health
okay let's let's get to heal out let's
get to hear that
[Music]
gosh
oh no this one ah
too many buttons
okay fine
wait can i look over there
evidently so jesus christ
okay yeah we're uh
they're backing up backing up back in
that bag
it said check
but uh it's not saying that anymore
from here you can see the whole area
below the waterfall there's the shrine
road wiped out by the landslide and the
path that leads up here
okay
oh wait what was that check
huh
where are we to check
said check but
did say track right yeah
there's a fork in the road the plants
here are slightly different than the
ones below the pool i must be close to
the unfathomable forest so it's quite a
small place in comparison to how big the
map is
okay when i press to see my
guardian angel oh okay it checks but it
says to go that way should we go this
way then let's go this way i'm a rebel
oh something shiny
okay the hands
[Music]
we need that
that's good thank you
i don't fully understand all of the
little add-ons that you can have for
your camera but
i'll get there
okay there's nothing around here the
tall fence blocks the path beyond is an
expansive forest that doesn't seem to be
anywhere around
okay
[Music]
uh
oh there's a hole in the fence
we got it we got it
ghost hands
oh she left her nose
i looked into mount kami it's always
been a spiritual place
not spiritual and holy but spiritual
isn't filled with the spirits of the
dead
maybe that's why it's a suicide spot
haruka wouldn't go in to die alone
though not without telling me the book
said people get spirited away to the
mountain they get cold towards it and
disappear alone
i read how it calls to people who are
perceptive anxious meek and who lack
family my heart skipped a beat when i
read that
i was describing her it was describing
heruka perfectly she was so kind and
accepting she always opens up to me
she's alert even when she seems to be
spacing out she knows what i'm thinking
maybe she was spirited away
but where do people go when they're
spirited away the more i think about it
the scarier it gets and the more my
heart stops pounding it starts pounding
[Music]
you should not follow a person who has
been spirited away
don't forget what teacher told you
and that's what this gal is doing
and hopefully we're not going to follow
in her footsteps because we're following
her
she's following his first away person
which means we're following his spirits
away from us and that's not good for
anyone
[Music]
the audio is very oh that's nice
cheese
what
there was someone by the shrine on the
other side of the road
i didn't see it
things happened so quickly here
there's something over there too
oh god
[Music]
uh
did it
suck up
hmm
i don't trust
sorry one second
got some feeling to do
hello
hold our tea and move ls
yes yes yes is there anything down here
though
[Music]
i'm just like yes the trace sure the
trace but where else can i go apart from
follow the trace oh look there's
something on the ground
ghost hands get ready for this ghost
hands good sounds good
i can't hold anymore why are you kidding
me
oh damn it
can't pick up anything
oh geez
get it
laying against the dead leaves
i don't know what to do now that
haruka's gone missing i can't do
anything on my own it's like i can't
breathe
we've been so close since we were
children
now she's gone i realize how important
she is to me how irreplaceable i can't
stop thinking
i could have done something when she
left i'd say maybe if i'd said something
i could have stopped her from going the
waiting is unbearable
i should have been the one to disappear
it should have been me
if robuka comes back there's so much i
want to tell her
i should tell her how i really feel
before we end things together maybe
she's already known for a long time but
i'll tell her anyway i have to tell them
oh
does she love her
hey orion's cafe i love that scare i've
been such a long time since i played
this i've never played this so
oh jesus [__] place mate
that's not good that's not good in the
slightest
oh gosh no no no no no no no no no no no
double kill double kill
oh scheisse
yeah that should be it that should be
oh [__] there's another one
come on peeps i'm with you
oh [__]
yes
okay
oh there's so many there's so many
there's too many please leave
[Music]
hello
are we playing
behind the trees
[Music]
she's a witch
geez
okay this game goes from like so slow to
then just being so fast
a crumpled note there's a slip of
crumpled paper on the ground seems to be
something written on it
the tales i read about mount verkami
were true
i can't handle any more death i've seen
that girl hang herself over and over
i've had enough
when i try to run i wind up back here
i find myself mimicking her
my body moved on its own just like that
girl
i felt i was doing the right thing as i
hung there my final thought was that
death takes a long time to come
i watched the sunset oh that's morbid
when i awoke i was back here i should
already be dead
will i be forced to see the sunset again
to go through it all again
i am fading bit by bit
let's go
okay well i'm glad we helped her
okay down this way
oh should we pick up some of those
things now
good sentence
how
i just used a bunch didn't i
am i not using them am i using am i
using different ones
i don't know where i'm going anymore
why is there things to pick up over
there
here they are as well
ghost towns ghosts hands
this is every time i feel like like
oh there's a spooky ass cave down there
what's this this is new
[Music]
sacred water clean water use of
purification source your health
that's a creepy creepy
wind echoes from the hole in the rocks
it's blowing up from underground the low
howl of the wind sounds almost like
somebody's voice
bye
i am sorry but
i really need to go toilet so i am gonna
go
and i'll be right back let me get my
cloak right seconds and
y'all can have a little bit of time to
chill
and not be as spooky scared
i don't wait where's my what's my
clothes doing
i mean if you want to take some time you
can also donate
to the fundraiser as well it's in the
chat the link and in the description as
well
so yes
i will see you all in a little bit
i'll be back
oh
i should probably just do this
[Music]
so
sorry mike muted i'm back
i was just telling you how much i really
needed that be and then i was wondering
why uh bergie was going
apparently i scared you baggy because i
came at the camera
my housemate is crazy what are you
talking about my housemate isn't in
right now
i'm on my own
classic yagman moment
oh crap sorry i left the door open
okay
screw you
getting rid of getting rid of the cloak
okay
so let's go down here
is this what we just tried to pick up
i'm pretty sure it is
is this where we came from there's so
many different pathways oh there's a
little tent here
hello
oh my god it's moving that's creepy
it's moving
ghost hands hands oh my god
nope from the tents the tenth rows i
know
how good the tent a scrap from a
notebook it looks like it fell from the
sleeping bag poking out of the tent
how long have i been here i suppose it
doesn't matter
i'm glad i decided to do things right
and come here to die
this place feels right
i thought i might get lonely but there
are people here people who aren't alive
this place may be as strange as people
say
i heard people children playing just now
i tried to get a look at them but they
ran off before i could close could get
close
did they come here on their own or were
they left here
earlier i heard the sound of a raspy
breath and running after that i heard a
scream
i was scared and held my breath
i'm not scared of death but that was
terrifying
i saw a woman dressed in white today she
was draped in cloth so i couldn't see
her face she seemed to stare at me for a
while then left
which side is she on i wonder will she
be back
i saw her again she turns up every day
watching me i feel her gaze but not her
presence
as soon as i noticed her she disappears
she must be constantly watching me
bruh i'm having nightmares why are you
having nightmares kieran
what are you talking about the way he
stood and watched her in the door
that's creepy
thanks for coming baggy
so i can't stay to watch with games with
friends make sure everyone donates thank
you as for working towards the gate
because oh that's so sweet thank you so
much for your help
and uh for your donation as well i
really appreciate it have a great
halloween thank you for being a part of
this stream it's it's been really fun so
far so yeah thank you
uh i heard a voice
a mournful voice like screaming
no like singing
it was a call of some kind but not for
me not yet
my time is yet to come
everything i've brought with me is gone
now i have nothing
i like it here nothing matters now this
was the right choice i'm glad i came she
will come soon she will take me away
she's calling i must go
something's going to happen once once i
put this note down
no
hello sir
you were moving just now aren't you a
small tattered tent has been put up i
can see what appears to be a sleeping
bag
but i'm not going to look any closer
because that's creepy as hell
i'm actually really glad that i went and
had to look there though
because that's
pretty cool
i just
like which way am i supposed to go get
up
that way okay
so what's up this way then i wonder
i want to look at everything now
oh i don't know i feel like i should
follow okay i'll follow it
[Music]
um
i can't even oh there you are
hello mister
i follow
what's over there
oh can i use the
that was cool did i get it i got it yes
nice
i'm so proud of myself right now oh yeah
do the movie
okay
nice
oh no we're at the creepy ass doll
shrine there
i don't want it
um wasn't there something in the water
that i could get
maybe
i swear i saw something oh it's up there
oh jesus [__] christ and jesus
i got the floor i got the flow i got the
floor
[Music]
come on
we run in here
we ain't ghost hunters we're running
today
[Music]
[__] jesus christ where is it i know
it's nearby where the [__] is it where
the [__]
no no i keep getting in the
[Music]
many i'm water die oh my god what
happens if i die
come on
we cannot die today
no [__] off you little [__]
i don't care if you're dead
i think i'm lost
oh no i shouldn't have done this to
myself
i got too greedy i just wanted the shiny
things now there's like ghosts
absolutely everywhere what the fridge
oh god and i don't even know where i'm
going
oh [__]
all off okay come on
whoa where is my man
no please
what are you telling me going underneath
me
i don't know which way it's letting me
go
which way do i go
okay
[Music]
oh god no
i just don't know i don't know where i'm
going anymore
this has suddenly gotten really hard and
whenever i do my whole like
men tell me where to go like i i don't
know where i'm going
i should have gone towards this freaking
doll's house
[Music]
oh [__]
which way am i running i i wish i had a
pointer to tell me which way i'm running
okay she is having a good time um
how do i get let's go to my items
sacred water
[Music]
okay
okay we just gotta figure out which way
we're going i can't i can't see the man
walking there's too many freaking ghosts
around here basically says
i just came from that way
why do i need to go that way
[Music]
they are everywhere and i hate them all
so much
i can't believe i'm so lost
i can't believe i got so lost
maybe i'm safe a bit now
oh god
where am i where's the map
where am i on the map
i don't even know
jack's really getting into character i'm
so lost though
isn't this back where we kind of started
you know if i just keep running i'm sure
we'll find it again eventually one day
we must be able to
see when i do this i don't even see a
person walking anymore
so how am i supposed to know if i'm
going the right way or not
i need to get to kooky off mountain
so i can't go this way
okay
where's my
guardians show me where to go
[Music]
okay it seems to want me to go this way
i don't know she looks towards this tree
every time
this way
nowhere
but there's something shiny up here so
i'm going up here
i don't care about going the right way i
just want to get some shiny shiny
shinies
those hands
i like it here i cannot die alone here
there's no one to stop me i can take
things slowly a peaceful dignified death
life is nothing but misery and suffering
and i'm stuck
no
there's more to it than that
i know it's
hard
thank you for meeting this
i'm gonna go down this way
back the way i came here that's where
you want me to go right yeah under here
okay okay well goodbye panda do this for
you
shiny
hands
they don't do it very often do they
manta said that they wouldn't but now
where
this way okay
oh good there i found you
oh my savior
we found we found we found the track
we're back on track we're back on jack
it's okay it's okay
oh my gosh
i love these dolls
countless dolls are lined up around the
shrine maybe this shrine used dolls in
its ceremonies they look like they've
been out here for quite some time
exposed to the elements
they don't look too battered up to me to
be honest
okay
i have
made my
you know bad decisions and i'm just
gonna follow the walking man now
oh god
the countless dolls smile vacantly
not spooky at all backing up backing up
backing up out of here
door's shut
can i use the uh
oh oh there's something on the floor
here
those hands
there's a page from a notebook on the
ground it looks like for you he is
writing
haruka and i have been close since
kindergarten we sang a song together at
graduation it was called the song of
memories haruka and i looked at each
other when we sang together and i'll
never forget that
i think about those times a lot lately
they were the best
i even had that tune
even if i hung that tune i started to up
hello little cutesy girl
[Applause]
hey kid noises it's creepy
okay there's something i can do here
imagine if they've moved
i shouldn't go in
she just left a note for me to find
hello
i'm following you closely now i'm not
i'm not going to lose you again i didn't
like it when i lost you
actually no i'm just gonna look around i
don't think there's anything around the
sides
okay i'm coming
[Music]
got them
gotcha
do i have to kill these
it's creepy
okay kids see you later
oh no but that's where the ghosts are
just went that way
it's not nice down here
oh gosh
[Music]
come on
i've already got all the shinies this
way
where where is it
yeah i went this way before see i had
the intuition
oh sure
she was pushed
nice
oh dear
uh
there's a cavernous hole open in the
ground looks like water has collected at
the bottom
if i fell in i don't think i could climb
back out
just like that what's that that was that
woman who keeps getting pushed in there
should we go
this way
oh i can't anyway okay that's probably
good there she is
for yuki
haruka she's here on the mountain
have you seen her
no but
she's here
i
i have to find her
[Music]
have they been here before
i wonder
[Music]
why did the two of us survive
we made a promise that we'd all die
together
oh
crap
[Music]
when will we get the chance
to join the others
so they'd already been here to commit
suicide but for some reason they
survived and now one of them's come back
and the other one i'll go and look for
haruka
let's go back
yes please
oh we're going back together right i
thought it was like end of this chapter
but no no no we're still
playing is that her night gown do you
think so i don't it looks like it is but
i'm sorry i don't mean to be judging
alone in a place like this
yeah i mean yeah it wouldn't be good
would it uh there's something shiny over
there should we go get it
i mean i'm not opposed to the idea
are you opposed to the idea
let's go
we know what happened last time i did
this
oh i don't think i can
okay whatever i can't go that way
hello you take forever can you run
oh my gosh
whoa
how did you do that you teleported
do you do that when because you hey why
are you walking okay come on this way
this way
oh no i don't have anyone to guide me
this time
do you know the way out okay
my game sense is telling me this way
this way
oh i probably under the street ramp
yeah
are you are you here you are
down here
[Music]
oh i did it too early
hey
that was good that was good
[Music]
that was not a good one
where are these
i want to get these kids
away from here because this is not a
nice place for kids to leave
so i want to help this kid
oh [__] no no please don't hug me
[Music]
i don't like hugs i'm not your mother
jesus
yeah i don't want to see you good
good
now what's your bloody guard
you think she went down there
how am i doing for like healthy stuff
i think i'm okay
i should be okay
oh
oh okay well she must be
uh
in the
chinese
demon children no they're not demons
oh they weren't trying to hurt me
actually so you might be right there
oh no she's gone into the shrine isn't
she
oh there she is okay good don't go in
it's gonna be scary in there
haruka she's here well the objective
updated goes by so fast i could not see
it
i don't know if you saw that because
it's behind the bar
she's here are you sure how do you know
[Music]
oh
come on let's go
you follow him
yeah good girl
no
no this way yeah good girl
okay
gtfo please
[Music]
yeah i saw the sages go
ghost hands
no
oh it's teacher
why is she in the water
what's with the reflection
oh no
so she got spurted away by me
close your eyes
[Music]
i know i'll remember you
play with me forever
[Music]
i think it is
such a waste of a purifying amber just
went straight back up again
in spring like a big pizza pie that's
some more
[Music]
play with me forever
i know
[Music]
oh [__]
no
no i don't like this i don't like it i
don't like it
[Music]
i got here
okay i guess i need to get her
um her object is not her face like i've
been doing it every other day
[Music]
i need to give myself some help
nice
so can i use this now or will it just
still
if it goes back up to fall again i'm
gonna be
stopped
oh [__]
hello
i'm helping i'm helping i'm helping
don't you worry
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
wow
she's in the raw family
[Music]
there we go
he
forgive me
uh
oh crap that's how she actually died
she's oh to do it
but i don't know i don't think it was i
think she just thought she saw her now
that is definitely something else
you've seen too much
[Music]
ghost attacks may leave you tainted by
the black water if this happens
i've already used two purifying enzes
and it just went straight back up
okay okay
we'll use another one
[Music]
she
you can't use it in quick succession
after the attack it's a lie i haven't
been able to do it once
it's alive
oh slanderously
how do i get them all in the shop oh
crap
oh no no no no no no no
[Music]
hey
i can see into your soul
[Music]
see every time i use this freaking
embers it just goes all the way back up
again so what is the point
[Music]
where is she now oh god
can't get them all can't get over
oh my god i had them for a second
oh no no they're gone again
oh there you go that was my quick
suspension succession
just got one extra
[Applause]
which way is she
i just don't think they work i'm gonna
have to do
google after this because i just don't
think they're working
oh damn what's she doing
i think i'm dying
[Music]
so because i wasn't quick enough to do
it
[Music]
things are too far away
go
oh gosh this woman is difficult
[Music]
that was that was quite
it's difficult
dangerous i can't stay here now i'll
have to get back for now
okay saving i think this is a good place
to end off um
thank you so much for watching oh geez
that was
interesting
feels nice to have a
little bit of a
stretch um
let's have a look at our goal how are we
doing
it looks like we're still on
hey
oh my gosh sorry i'm kidding i'll burp
you again 826 which is so freaking good
like 400 original goal and now we've got
826 pounds raised for women's trust it's
amazing thank you so much um
as for the game
uh i saw some of you asking me yeah
kieran will you play the fall game on
stream and then michael said i guess it
depends on how long the game is and um
yeah i am intending to
um but so what i was thinking was
because uh
i would like to transition over to
full-time streaming no not full-time i i
can't do that to streaming on twitch
only and not youtube so that then i can
hopefully become a twitch affiliate um
so i might continue this on twitch only
and then because i've still got alan
wake to
to finish as well i want to play adam
wake and finish alan wake so if i do
play more of this it'll probably be on
twitch only i'm not quite sure when um
but if you're in the discord then you
can
follow
me with with the with all of that and
when i'm doing that i'll put actually a
link to the discord here now for anyone
who might not be in the skills
there
good job everyone thank you
good job everyone
good job everyone oh right i thought you
meant about the game no good job
everyone for raising money yes this is
what delay does it confuses me because i
can't get lost in the conversation
yeah good job everybody
good job everybody
good job everybody we have raised 826
pounds and that is absolutely amazing
literally
so sure
i'll double check but i'm pretty sure
it's the most that we've raised in any
charity stream so
you should be proud you should all be
proud
um i am going to take my second break of
the stream now so i can have a little
bit to eat
and recharge me batteries before coming
back and playing more video games
for you
uh with my friends this time i think
we're gonna play phasmaphobia
and uh that's going to be interesting
because it's had a lot of updates
recently
um so
i want to figure out or try out what
those updates are
and hopefully i'm really hoping
phasmophobia is going to get back to
being really scary because you remember
when i first started playing it i found
phasmaphobia terrifying i screamed all
the time it just it was extremely
anxiety juicy
and then i got used to it and i got used
to the ghost mechanics and everything
else and just got kind of boring and
samey but they've added new maps new
ghosts they've kind of changed the way
that you interact with the items there
so
i think it's going to be
interesting is the onion king coming in
yes yes it's gonna be me onion king
tom as well and uh sleepiest jenny i
think she's been on this channel once
before but she's extremely lovely and
you'll love her um so yeah they are all
going to be here so come back and join
me at 8 30.
um i'm just gonna push this once more
just in case anyone hasn't um donated
and wants to uh of course you don't have
to if you don't want to it's perfectly
fine um but here is the donation
link
yeah eight before the stream got hungry
just had a sandwich yeah i ate before
the stream now i'm hungry so i'm gonna
go
have some soup soup soup soup
coffee time oh wow i couldn't i couldn't
have coffee this late montage i think
i'd be buzzing
all night long
unless it's decaf obviously but
oh yeah thank you colin once again colin
has just been mvp with this charity
donations
decaf like life hacks yeah there you go
decaf
super does not fill me up
i i think it depends on what type of
suit because i used to think the exact
same thing but then i started to make my
own soups so i think it might be the
soups that you get like from the
supermarket and stuff i think they water
them down and stuff so that you pay more
to get less but when i make my own soups
they're so chunky and like
full of stuff
that it does fill me up
also obviously have some bread on the
side
a little dip dip dip
yeah there you go my test said it too
spread on the side dip but yeah i think
i remember i used to get like the really
just it's just water like water tomato
soup from like a can nah no thank you no
thank you but if you make it yourself
you know how much is going in there you
know that it's probably going to fill
you up
oh you don't need to thank me for the
live stream malakai but that's nice of
you thank you for coming
it's been really lovely and it's not
over yet so
yeah
gosh i still can't believe how much
we've raised it's so good it's so good
i'm so proud of us
okay i'm gonna go uh
have a bit of food and then i will see
you back here at uh
eight o'clock isn't it yeah so in about
half an hour i'll be back here with my
friends i'm playing for some player
phobia so
see you then everybody
bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye
[Music]
hello everybody we are back
i don't know if anyone stuck around but
whoever did thank you
uh we are going to play some phasma
my friends we got here tom
hello
jenny
hi
and uh onion where where is onion
where's braden brayden
patent
where even i
are you in here
i'm here around
where
actually where though
[Laughter]
oh
has that happened to you two before
yes this is with the new halloween oh my
gosh
you see the footprints you're supposed
to follow the footprints in the uv light
oh and that's when you go over there but
i just went over because yeah i know i
was looking for breath
behind the door
oh my gosh
you [__] [__] yourself
i nearly cried
oh
but yeah so as you can see chat phasma
phobia has had major updates and uh
we're gonna be playing today
uh jenny knows a bit more about the
updates the rest of us are basically
clueless um
and jenny doesn't even know that much so
we're kind of all going in a bit blind
so
yeah yeah i've added a bunch of new [__]
i don't really know about so yeah new
ghosts new i don't know other stuff
it's like an entirely new way to play
this is a little bit
intimidating that's cool
you can uh you can follow the arrows on
the ground as well
oh arrows oh yeah oh no oh no someone's
coming
did you did you open this yeah
i opened it
[Laughter]
you're not supposed to like
follow the arrows and you go over there
and then the
skeleton falls out on you oops
this is cool though right with like the
pentagrams this is so cool yeah i love
this oh
there's a guy at the top as well and
they're like rafters
oh my god that's so cool it's like limbo
i love when you guys are looking upwards
your backs are like
that's the thing that i i thought was
hilarious it's been so much updated and
he's like but the the characters
nah [__] that like the player character
masks on them like they're perfect
it's fun playing someone vr as they get
scared yeah i can i i think i would just
cack myself if i was playing this in vr
i'm i'm a scaredy cat at the best of
times
yeah perfect
oh you guys are like okay so we've got
level 12 level 13 level one and level
148. oh my gosh like i'm more of a pro
than i am this was before the updates
wow
um well i have no money so you guys are
gonna have to bring in all the equipment
yeah
oh yeah forgot about that
um for the chat and also for you guys
we've managed to raise what is it now a
hundred no eight and not a hundred a
measly amount eight hundred
and twenty six pounds uh for women's
trust so thank you so much to everyone
who has donated so far and uh look out
for the link in the chat and in the
description if you want to donate as
well
big money and thank you fobington for
following
oh hey bob
oh you know
oh yeah
friends made sure to bring some pals
thank you
okay right
what do we need so we need uh the radios
if we're going to do in-game audio
i mean it looks like jenny's brought in
a lot of everything
yeah i brought most things you you
always have the walkie-talkies you don't
need to buy those oh okay that's good
now the money
thanks for following me
instinctively
instinctively reading chat
uh what what
what do we need
uh the head mounted cameras new two
windows
i think i can put those in
do they not do strong flashlights
anymore
no they do they're like right at the
bottom of the list though oh
okay
you'll have to change your change your
game on twitch yes oh thank you thank
you for reminding me
that's right
oh my god yeah i was playing fatal frame
and uh
so much boob jiggle i was like why
whenever the camera changed angle her
boobs just went crazy and i was like i
can't be scared i'm too distracted
so funny
so i i vaguely know what i'm that i've
got uh
do i have to take photos of stuff we
need to find evidence of ghosts
yeah
all right as a evidence
so that's stuff like
gross
toilets i don't know no you don't need
to
grow sinks grow sinks sinks yeah
yeah thanks for following ray nori
hi
uh so but is it so what's the is that
like our best
oh look at this man limbo
right it'll be a lot less scary if uh if
anyone's seen that entire time
uh
all right i mean
how do we start
do we have everything that we need yeah
what what uh what difficulty we're gonna
do uh okay let me have a look at my jobs
because i'm i'm a lower uh lower level
so i think i can only do certain
difficulties
um oh would it would it make sense for
jenny to host so we can do like i think
it's open i think everything's open
there are new things look there's a
maple lodge campsite i've never been
there before but that's the new one i
think that's brand new i can either do
instead of the outdoor one or amateur
oh intermediate is perfect i think
amateur will be
too easy i i i'd rather die you know
okay literally
all right well all right ready when you
are
um
ready up
did you decide to stand next to my head
so you could speak that loudly
[Laughter]
i'll have to read yet
thank you for following tortupola
are these all your friends
oh yeah
they can't hear me anymore because it's
we're doing the in-game voice things oh
here they are oh
hello hello
i was talking to you and then i
remembered you couldn't hear me because
the uh
it was once the game was loading all i
had was braden in my face walking slowly
and forever on the spot
just intimidatingly staring me down like
you were going to knife me
i mean yes
have they changed oh they still got a
creepy picture here this creepy picture
like scares me because you're the
amitable horror house like the real
amityville horror house so you see the
banister with the boy peering across
that's a real photo that they took in
the amateur horror house when they left
a camera in in the hallway just taking
pictures they took a picture of an
actual boy and that's the real picture
and it scares me oh
i don't like it
oh no no no so what what's the head
things on the wall that what do these do
these are head cams so when you come to
the computer you can flick through our
head camps oh cool cool
they have updated the uh
props on this
they have so does anyone have an
emp or like a heaty
[Music]
yes where are they
these ones i
think you want to try your uh
walkie-talkies
see if the
button works
hello
when you when you're using the
walkie-talkies uh hold them down for
longer than you talk just a little bit
because it cuts off sometimes at the end
of sentences
oh actually while i'm here i am going to
change that button to bx
oh also you should check out the the new
journal yeah jonah's cool
i can just hear jasmine scrolling
uh how do we get up the journal again
so if you get jenny do you want to
explain the evidence
yeah
so if you go to your evidence tab now
you can click off if you've got emf but
if you tap the emf again it strikes it
out so if you know it's definitely not
something
you can strike it out and it'll still
show you
like more information on it very cool
so you don't have to think so much you
just have to press buttons yeah which is
better there's so many new ghosts i
thought he was just gonna add like two
know it's so [__] my name
all right
oh so i've got an emf reader a
flashlight and whatever this is what's
this
uh
that's
put the gameboy down
oh i could put it oh it's like a
proximity sensor maybe it's either like
a motion or a sound sensor i can never
put on the wall right
oh those are the sound ones i think i
think the right ones i hope it's got
tetris
what's the where's the spit oh you got
the spirit box already okay
yeah
and i got camera you have like a book
and stuff oh yeah what's our objectives
oh yeah emf reader okay
oh a candle blow out a candle i'll bring
a candle
okay
catcher i've got a book you should you
need to bring a lighter as well
uh if you have a lighter on with f in
your hand and then you switch to like
the
candle or whatever and press f it lights
it i believe it's how it works okay
i can carry a candle light i didn't i
could never figure it out
i mean i've got i got salt now i've got
salt
oh you have a candle anymore no
thinks there's like a whole team working
on this now not just one
dude oh
oh this is this is locked it's foggy
oh yeah that's it
look at it
oh wait open oh
you got the key oh it's bright you just
have to click it a beer
is that a ghost ball
oh wait what's the ghost did we look at
the map at all i didn't look at them oh
my god you actually run a bit faster now
that's good
hello charles
is that is that the name of the ghost
charles
yeah charles clark
little baby kitty tents
everyone was murdered here yasmin please
oh have a little respect
oh marshmallows that's some good looking
marshmallows
i'm not seeing anything around here
oh i don't know where to go
is what's this can you get in here
that's a big old pinto
oh there's a guitar
oh yeah you can play it
no way
oh my god i just looked over to you and
saw a [__] figure with no light
standing over the guitar looking
terrifying
well this has been a whole lot of
nothing so far
no ghosts time to go home
oh that's a very bright door lodge
i braided oh my god
[Laughter]
oh my god it's so bright
oh we found a house i feel like i'm
playing alan wake oh yeah jasmine go to
the end of the pier
go to the to the end of the pier to the
under the beer over here
over here go to the end of it
it's actually three degrees on the pier
which is
probably
degrees
why do i go to the end of the pier
look in the water at the front of the
pier
oh
spoopy there's a mask oh wait do i need
to take a picture of it
i don't know might as well
wait do i need to like get that nah
that's fine
no where's brayden
i don't know
can we get inside the house yeah
can we pick it up pick it up yeah
i got it they can get in the house
nice
hi bro
oh you can play the piano
how cute
you're very good
wait can you actually
actually play notes or is it just random
i played keyboard when i was nine
i'm surprised
yeah no bones
it was almost cold outside like right in
the pier
in the lake
oh the lady of the lake
have you got any info for us charles
who did you murder charles who killed
you charles
yeah charles
[Laughter]
oh
give us a sign
you know with the spirit box do you need
to press anything to make it work
i mean you need to know it's doing that
static noise it's on yeah okay you can
ask it questions on yeah charles are you
here
give us a sign
he likes to be talk to people who are
alone so how do you know that
says in the journal
no
yes
whoa
the flashlight is so strong
a volunteer jasmine
what why you gotta go
you got the career box
oh well am i okay bye
i'll just sit here
you can talk to us on the microphone
is this the whole map so we explored
everywhere now
give us a sign uh yeah pretty much
charles are you here
oh my god wait something just moved i
didn't do that something just moved i
can move right okay how old are you
charles
why did you kill
okay give me another sign is there
always like a bone to find or is that a
special treat
i definitely saw him
this game
yeah he was by the end here
yeah i tried to get a picture but i
failed i was too busy screaming did we
see someone yeah there was a man and he
was gonna come and stab me he was here
oh
okay
i ran towards him for some reason
oh yeah so sorry people watching please
put your speaker level down i'll put my
level down a little bit
how do i put the salt down it's already
down the lowest it'll go uh is it f
maybe
ah yeah there you go
okay so it just knocked the book off the
thing
yeah it it knocked it knocked one of my
cans over as well so it can definitely
move things
oh
goes
okay we should go get more amount of
salt
yeah okay i'm gonna go back and get
something
what
yeah you can knock open them
oh
i thought i heard something when i was
over here but it was during your ghost
experience so i imagine
probably oh jesus oh i thought i heard
something whilst on the other side of
the [__] map you're getting stabbed
the scariest thing was though i thought
it was one of you oh
i thought it was one of you and then i
realized it was like way too big and
holding a knife and i was like no
there's not one of them
yeah i don't think i have a knife in my
hand this time no
this time step by day like
all right what do we need
okay okay so spirit box what are we
trying to do for our stuff
um i'm gonna take a tripod on a camera
oh hey uh i didn't have the emf mirrored
turned on at all
nice
okay
i just thought it was turned on oh my
gosh
it wasn't turned on at all
oh my god okay
wait what uh our brains aren't looking
great
no i don't
[Music]
what else should i bring so i put some
salt down
uh can you bring a candle cause i've got
a lighter but i can't pull like a candle
in the wind
i've got a uv torch i don't know if
anyone else has been
using this
no no no
[Laughter]
did you sit there with your crucifix
we got camera do we have a camera i've
got a camera yeah i tried to take a
picture of him earlier but i just was
too scared
yeah i thought sir
did you hear me
of course i heard ya
[Laughter]
i think the ghost has silenced him
oh no
all i heard was he said are you talking
and then tom just going like
yes i'm talking
we i can hear like a little bit
occasionally but not like
oh no
sentences
[Music]
[Laughter]
okay
okay well
all right i'm gonna look for footprints
or something
oh hello charles
charles show yourself so i can take a
picture i'm a photographer i'm quite a
good one
i'll edit it afterwards to make you look
really nice
i heard you here
it's comeback he's
oh yeah hello
hello
hello i don't know what that was about
there was a heartbeat over there we
heard him he was with he was like
breathing in my ears here
so maybe it's just all around here like
outside the house somewhere
um
well maybe i'll move this
tom could you put the candle on the
ground
oh my god
oh guys i found uh something on the
floor here
oh
oh yeah oh he's been in there he's been
in the summer oh yeah oh take a picture
of that let's get that on we take a
photo oh oh oh oh oh happy happy
heartbeat hello
heartbeat
not today no no visitors
is it humming as well
where was he
i don't know i couldn't just freaking
nothing
have we got a camera for these
is that a fingerprint oh yeah i've got a
camera what do i take
do i take the the salt
and the uv light probably
oh uh
i'm gonna have to give the uv light to
someone then so they can hold it while i
take a picture oh it's gone now it's not
there anymore
oh yeah i think they disappear now
pretty quick i think
i think it blew out the candle oh
that's an objective i think
oh yeah it is
yeah
okay you got your emf reader on tom yeah
it's on i'm not saying she's good just
making sure what's happening i also
there was nothing it wasn't on like it
was on during his heartbeat
nothing's come up
i was thinking maybe i should go back
into the house and check it out thanks
for following mega stinkman play
what a name make a steak man was it in
the house
well the thing said to get an emf
reading
but we've not found anything
i mean it was outside though it was out
here when it's born
oh [__] [__]
where is it
gotcha
beach okay i'm audi i'm audi
i got a nice good picture
nice
emf definitely went up but i don't know
if it went to five
uh we have ghost on the camera oh nice
[Laughter]
he looked very stabby
he didn't laugh
you see why i was scared now
all right what we got so far
oh we did all these tips oh evidence oh
evidence i didn't say to do five
there was emf but it wasn't five i don't
think ghost orbs okay spirit box oh wait
no because he didn't talk back to me
oh okay so it's not bad we didn't get
freezing temperature either or we didn't
get ghost riding either
does fingerprints definitely count as
their like footsteps as well
uh
no i think they're different
i think well no okay um
so we didn't have emf level five
no it went up but i don't think it went
to five
footsteps don't count as fingerprints
did you say you saw fingerprints braden
i thought that was footprints i thought
i counted the same thing but i don't
know all right okay okay so we need to
get a dots projector then i guess
which one's the dots one is it we didn't
have freezing temperatures
no
did you bring a dots
i think it's a photo guys
okay we got a picture which one's the
dots
we've got mostly objectives done
yeah
i got a picture
we should figure out what it is we don't
have a book do we for the ghost playing
yeah we put the book down oh yeah she's
not doing anything
but they didn't
it wasn't did you try again with the
spirit box maybe i didn't do it enough
oh cool
yeah it looks cool
well he appeared but he didn't talk to
me through the spirit box he just
started to like move stuff around me so
if if we if we cancel we didn't get emf5
we didn't get ghost writing or freezing
temperature or spirit box
if you scroll if you cross all those out
with ghost orbs the only thing it could
be is a banshee
i think we should go back one more time
because we've got the dots projector now
okay i'll do it baby
uh it's the one i have now it's the oval
one the mixture do you see that it looks
pretty cool
can you really see it from the camera oh
that's [__] braydon
[Laughter]
all right i'm going back i'm just gonna
watch braden get murdered on the camera
it would be fun
all good that brings me
the lights the lights are gone
oh my gosh
oh oh [__] is he is he dead oh my gosh
did he just die
no he's not dead he's trying to get
right in there are you okay right in
oh no
look on the board is he dead
oh [__] he's dead
he said she just like there's nothing
here
guys
he was very unimpressed said that
nothing was there and then died so be
careful
his final word yeah
okay well it's up to you we can either
go back out there or
just oh that is quite a cool shot though
on this pc it's very ominous that's his
body yeah
his dead body
now braden's a ghost so braden is now
walking he can hear us but we can't hear
him brave and high have you done all
right
this is what you get for going off on
your own hey i've got 16
yeah we're not doing too hard
should we try and make a guess like so
we didn't get ghost writing that we put
the book down we didn't get freezing
temperatures that we went with the
thermometer
uh
we did get ghost orbs
yep you didn't get anything from the
spirit box
we don't know about fingerprints we
don't know about dots i got amf but it
wasn't five
yeah
so if you scratch all those out the only
thing is bouncy i could be wrong this is
my first ever game
but also
yeah
i mean it it can't be a poster guys
because that
when you say yes to ghost job that gets
crossed out so
right um what's the opaque
well the ban she says will only target
one person at a time
if that says anything about brazen
getting murdered
and he only showed oh no because he he
did appear
together
do we want to take a photo of his body
for like insurance or whatever do we
have to do oh [__] yeah
yeah okay
well i guess we don't have to do that
but we can
i mean let's go come on it's really fast
maybe maybe we'll find the emf when
we're out here and i'll be proven wrong
yeah yeah i'm sure braden's spirit will
protect us
yeah he won't start throwing random
canvas and stuff
jaded scientist says in one nightmare
in nightmare difficulty a ghost killed
their entire group in one hunt oh my god
yeah because hunts don't end after
you've killed someone in nightmare mode
it's insane just carry on forever it's
ridiculous
okay i'm gonna put a dot projector down
in front of the camera too done
look how cool it is
you're too heavy sorry
you're too happy
let's go
i love that three of the teammates got
killed and then every all three of them
were just throwing items at him for the
rest of the game
no a little hunt must have happened oh
and it launched behind us
okay so we're gonna say banshee right
i think so so i guess
uh
yeah i guess we can
okay let's let's uh all right close up
shop
rest in peace braden
thanks for following
i'm so sorry i just butchered that
completely i just don't know how to say
your name
you left me
your spirit came with us it's fine
[Laughter]
did you figure out what it was
oh not really we think maybe maybe a
banshee wait did we get it right i
didn't even look i think we did i think
we did it popped up at the end
let's go
ghost hunter
all
right what do we have man you'd have to
be a real noob to die on that map
that was literally my first ever game of
phasmophobia
the way you died braden was hilarious
because you were just like oh there's
nothing here and then all of a sudden
you're because we were watching your
like headcam and it just went and we
were like uh i think he's dead
do we need to stock up any more stuff
uh
i think we're
good okay
everyone in chat expecting me to die
i'm a ghost hunter extraordinaire
[Music]
okay so there is i'll let you
know what's available so you can choose
um so there's some street houses that it
looks like i've been in before
there is a farmhouse i don't know if we
there's two different farmhouses
i don't know if i've been there's
bliesdale and grafton
there is the high school
an asylum and a prison i know we've been
in the asylum prison before
are those those are the really big ones
right they saw them in the prison yeah
they're they're quite large
okay i will definitely get lost in those
let's not do those ones
yeah do another small house whichever
one all right what do i have
let's do a farmhouse accident if we've
done this
all right ready when you are
i'm trying to breathe into braden's ear
tommy
up
top asmr
there hello
[Music]
donald
people who are alone
okay
nice um
[Laughter]
i'll take a temperature thing i guess
have a member of the team escape the
ghost during a hunt detect it with a
motion sensor prevent it from hunting
with a cruise effect which can lead to
the spirit sensor
the white one the right
one maybe no oh um
which one is this
i'm i'm gonna just grab one of those i
think it's i think it's that one
that's enough for me
i've got a crucifix and an emf reader
okay
sweet where you going
i don't know what this thing is what's
this what
is that
[Laughter]
what is it
is it an oval thing i can't see
yeah it looks like it's like a really
shitty pokedex that
does it do anything when you oh yes
that's the dots projector oh you want to
put it like uh outside and then pack and
when you're oh i'll take this as well
what else have you got
uh temperature okay oh it's snowing
gentle snow oh i'm cute
i heard that apparently the developer
was going to put like ghosts in the
windows watching you
so what's the night for that i don't
know if that ever happened or if it's
just something that i read
[Music]
where are you oh they've got gherkins
nice
i love a good guy
uh why don't we put
[Laughter]
[Music]
for you
uh
who has that reader
only in that door frame
where are you
oh you just got my trick maybe it's
above us
oh it stopped beeping it's no longer
beeping
give me a sign
birdie
there's like a there's like an outside
area behind
oh that's so bright
where are you
are you in here
oh donald
give me a sign
anything in those back rooms
uh i mean i didn't see anything i've
been in here so many times and the ghost
is like has been in this room but
oh where are you
where tom saw the
emf stuff as well
oh maybe
oh here
hello the door is closing oh what was
that yeah
where are there you are
okay it's definitely in this door frame
uh
oh
one
got a two
okay uh should i put this on the fridge
i'll put this on the fridge
can i can i put this can i can i drop
the emf
yeah you can put it on the ground
um
i think it's like f g or something
okay hopefully it'll walk through the
door and then
we shall see it
okay
cold freezing temperatures
on that side
only it's
i don't know i'm looking at it you're
fine
look at the door frame basically i'm
getting cold temperatures
do we have a
uh uv light
who are you uh not with us
i can get one
[Laughter]
oh no we left jenny on her own
i'll come back
oh she's coming back
oh my god oh my god guys
the ghost is a pianist
it played the piano
how do i do this
how do i do this so
yeah
oh gosh
yep definitely freezing temperatures are
down there
you want to put get one of these boys
on the right
okay
oh yeah press f on it i don't know why
she's gonna
and then grab it by the tripod is that
braided
when you pull it back on
oh yeah
i can't grab it by the tripod
okay so
oh my god
[Laughter]
maybe i will [__] it
bye jaded scientist where are you going
or is it going i think maybe it's going
by it
put you
okay
oh bye breaks the light i think it was
very exciting i was going i'm sorry i'm
getting confused
and thanks for coming
oh man you run out of stamina so quick
is the camera set up now
why
where is the camera
mouse to swap camera maybe not this one
yay
okay so we don't got any no no orbs or
anything
maybe i'm going to put the motion sensor
on the other side because it seems like
more oh it was something that happens on
the other side oh
i couldn't tell if that was an over if
that was just braden's head
i
please no i want to watch another one of
my friends get murdered on camera
oh maybe
yeah usually there's like a couple of
them but
i don't know about you but i'm noticing
that uh most of the
stuff is happening on the other side of
the door frame
like oh the other room not this one yeah
the cold breath is happening on the
other side
so i'm going to move my motion sensor
and put it on the the opposite side
good thinking who's there oh it's braden
why is braden just so fine to just be on
his own i just don't understand
brave too brave
is it bravery though
[Laughter]
uh could you write the book please
be very helpful
on the head jesus
[Laughter]
wait i missed it what happened
very spooky
it like slammed the door that was in
but i didn't see anything
no i didn't either oh that's so weird
you write the book
[__]
all right
i'm not seeing any
like fingerprints or anything
yeah
[__] here it is
i just hate it when it's in my ears
it was right behind you it was right
behind me was it
oh yes it was
oh the crucifix worked
oh sick yeah let's go
oh nice
i saved your life
in
oh
[Music]
[Laughter]
[__] okay so what have we got what
haven't we got
so
it got freezing temperature yeah
i haven't seen any fingerprints no the
ghost did the ghost did the ghost write
in the book
i haven't looked
jenny tried spirit box but she didn't
get anything did she
you can try bro
yeah okay
yeah
so the only thing remaining if we get
rid of most of that stuff is revenant
but isn't the revenant like one of the
aggressive ones
i don't know to be honest oh what's that
noise did you hear that noise
oh dining room what's that what's the
red thing oh sound sensor oh that's
that's braden
yeah that's braden
okay
i still haven't got the motion yet so i
think i
i just don't know where to put it
give us a sign
i'll leave him alone
daddy old
i think spirit box is a logo
i've got the uh the sound thing now
oh okay
oh footsteps is that no we can't use
that in the journal can we
take photos of it though have you taken
a photo do we have a camera yes
can you take a photo of jenny's body as
well oh i did
nice don't worry
so he's like in this room right
[__]
[Music]
activities
can you open the front door
no
uh tom just
can you open the door for me
am i doing am i being stupid or is it
locked
oh my god don't do that
i hate you
i need to take a picture of the body
come with me i don't want to come alone
where is he
where did he die
oh poor tom
okay
let's just go
we still didn't get like a motion sense
either
no ghost orbs i guess
no fingerprint no ghost writing
oh [__] where was the book
right in the center did you look at it
there's nothing there yeah yeah there's
nothing there
sound sensors are going off
okay
um
[Music]
so we literally only have freezing
temperatures to go on
well yeah but we can cross out ghost orb
spirit box and go fighting
ghost dog spirit box and ghost writing
okay so it's gin orinoni
wait let me have a look at those types
jyn
jenny's territorial ghost attack when
threatened
jim will travel at a faster speed this
victim is far away turning off the
locations by our source will prevent jim
from
and what's the other one and oni
uh
shares traits with demons and for this
extreme strength they have been rumored
they've become more active around their
prey only they're more active when
people nearby and have been seen moving
objects okay we haven't seen any objects
move have we
i don't know so june
let's go with jyn
sure
okay ready to go
uh wait wait wait wait wait wait uh
uh
yes i am
fingers crossed
this changes scientists i'm so happy
that tommy's late
yeah
i was right
it wasn't it oh let's go
i i said
so he's in this room right and then he
immediately appeared and killed me oh my
gosh
it was uncanny how quickly he appeared
and he was so fast
he's got a habit of doing that jaded
scientist was very happy that you were
dead
i ran a
dmd game for jaden scientist that was
horror
spooky murder
business boot
very fun very fun
okay anything you need me to add
we've got a little bit of everything
oh do we need another flashlight
i think um
that's right it's all right
oh wait sugar sugar
cupboard light flashlight
she's our sugar daddy
oh wait no you got one okay cool
yeah i think everything's fine now i
just have to rebuy because i died well
the head mountain cameras but if we're
not using that it doesn't matter too
much
um what's that something
head mounted camera bye oh pills is a
good idea
we've got four pills now nice
i think we're good we got my stuff
no idea what that darts projector
does it you can like see the ghost
sometimes
it's cool
okay what we got here
let's go for a house this time
smaller much uh more likely to get
murdered
might have a ouija board in it
i'm i'm into these i'm into the emf
reader i like i like a little bit of uh
beep you know
i like the danger beeps
i'm ready operator oh my god oh sorry
geez you're such a noob
[Music]
okay
um i'm i'm bringing temperature again
kenneth miller
and
a spirit box
it's got a camera and a dark thing
all right
ghosts ghosts hello ghosts ghosts
kenneth
okay it's miller
who are alone
yeah you should be able to use his name
to anger it and get some paranormal
activity
hi it's the spookiest okay what's the
name kenneth miller
have i been in this house this might be
new oh
look at that
what do you mean cute
so cool
okay yeah this is a new house oh
look at that big tv wow
nice time
we're fall off though
good boy
hey girl
superstar dj
do we have to oh it up
yeah
hold our skull
that's a bone
that's actually a bunch of bones
oh no that's a bone
[Laughter]
is
[Music]
oh
wow what a beautiful painting
oh that is nice
oh
i regret turning that on i'm sorry i
turned on the alarm clock
kenneth
hello give us a sign that's a little
teddy locked away
i'll help you teddy
i want to pick it up
oh he's got a fan on the ceiling
he had locked away a teddy in her little
closet
oh that's [__] up kenneth
how dare you oh yeah kenneth it is
triple monitors
wait what
oh wow
kenneth are you here
let's turn off some lights
if you leave too many lights on it blows
the fuse
ah
i didn't know that yes
oh kenny boy
see if you turn on lights just make sure
you turn them up afterwards
thanks for following rack rack wax wax
let's get something for somebody follow
us today is it because
is it because of you that i'm getting
followers
uh some of them
thank you
okay where am i
where's everyone
this particular garage area reminds
what you kind of cut off there i don't
know what you said what's it where
is everyone alive
[Laughter]
i'm alive there's only one floor to this
place right oh well on the basement
yeah yeah okay
oh
wow nearly freezing or freezing
like one celsius
so it's gotta be around here surely
bye jaded
bye
kenneth
[Music]
i'll just leave that there for now
we can move it later
they're like people on their own so
maybe someone
in there in here on their own
okay
okay bye
that's not alone if you're both together
we're alone together
can you give us a sign
i'm leaving your brain
why is there like a camera and a light
just left here
oh i brought that in i think there's
something is there
oh [__]
when will you
learn saw that he died on the tripod
ah
oh god
this is a mess
okay
oh jesus christ
oh jesus
okay
[Music]
oh man
this is what i get for being a
photographer of the group
i'm very dead okay hello guys
hello
at least we're frankton
dead together now
how do we pick things up to throw it
right in front of me
this is what it was like when you died
and we were talking about how funny it
was how you died
is it e to pick things up do i have
something i have something okay let me
go over to them and see what happens
where are you are you there i'm behind
you i don't know
[Laughter]
we didn't have anything right
no not really it didn't go to freezing i
don't think no i don't think they said
it got very cold but not quite freezing
okay
do we try spirit box
[Laughter]
as well
one more thing and then we'll just
double split
okay all right so yeah we'll try one
more thing we don't wanna i'm gonna do
spirit box no sorry uh yeah it's pretty
cool i have a cup
sorry sorry whoever's cup i stole
um
okay i'm gonna
take up
no and we just didn't notice
yeah
all right we're gonna we're gonna we're
gonna ask questions quick you're both
too worried about kenneth what about the
guys getting killed yeah
yeah that makes sense
kill jasmine
[Laughter]
yeah
kenneth why are you so rude
can we shut the door
oh that would be cool
yes
where is it oh there it is i see it
oh is this spooky it's gonna get tough
it's gonna get tough it's gonna get
tough
oh it didn't get toned
i didn't get some it didn't get him
[Laughter]
open the door yeah when i was by the
front door i couldn't hear anything or
nothing was wrong with my stuff so i
didn't know it opened the [__] ghost
opened the door of the bathroom and then
disappeared oh brady you're gonna stay
in the house are you gonna haunt it
oh you're there
yeah
so it's a hand too apparently that's the
only thing that could be there right
red that can be found in hotter climates
known to attack often during cold
weather
low temperatures allow the hunter to
move faster squeeze and move slower and
warm areas jesus christ
that's useless that's [__] useless
i guess i thought your russell's wrong
let's go let's get out of here
i wouldn't have waited for them to put
the hunter in
oh
what was the evidence for the demon
i don't know
horn
we watched um that follow you into the
bathroom and we were like oh yeah it's
gonna get tom and literally walks into
the bathroom and then just disappeared i
don't know how it didn't get you so i
just chucked a laptop at you
i was hiding in the corner i was hiding
in the corner and then i saw the door
open and i was like [__] [__] [__] [__]
[__] [__]
and then he came into the room and
disappeared and i saw a laptop [__]
dropping my face
oh it was so good
oh my goodness
well we didn't get it right
but i didn't die
yeah
[Laughter]
um i just need to take a little quick
pee break so i'll be right back me too
well
we will be right back
why okay
does that mean we've been left with
stream
i don't know
yes you have okay
i'll mute it so you can talk and stuff
oh okay i'll leave it on music then
okay okay
now there's a lot of pressure for you
you especially to be very entertaining
hello chad how are you doing today
how's the weather am i right
that's what people do right
are we hearing a slight echo through
yeah thanks brayden's mic
oh well maybe
wait i'm standing next to braden thank
you jack oh it's louder thanks for
watching yeah
really cold oh it's real bad i'm sorry
it's raining
what's up see
you're so entertaining
you should consider you should consider
accuracy okay here's my next question
how do you eat more teasers what's your
way of eating maltesers
i just you just
what do you mean like did you use do you
suck them do you like
the outside oh that's
well that's all right okay
i'll just put it in my face
tom last round the ghost walked right up
to you literally in your face really i
saw it open the door
and walk into the room but i didn't see
it in my face
i'm back
hello brayden
hi
i have a very slight echo from your mic
that's not good
we've determined that it's from you by
standing in between you and yasmin and
then talking loudly
my michael just muted that
what the [__]
oh wait can you wait were you
oh okay that's weird i don't know i
don't know i don't know man
i don't know man that's weird
it despawned as it got to you oh well
i'm just an expert ghost hunter
what can i say apart from the fact that
i got that last one wrong and then the
previous to that i died
yeah apart from those apart from those
things
this is definitely a bit more harder
than last time we played because last
time was just like we rattled it off you
know if we go so i didn't die and now
since you're getting killed left right
center
yeah
and spookier and scarier yeah the
evidence is harder to get before you'd
be like oh mf5 done temperature's done
but i guess it's because they've had
they've added more variety in the things
that it's going to demonstrate right so
it's a little bit trickier
true
but it feels like you have to try like
multiple times to get things
like sometimes uh things will only seem
to work after one person dies
is what i've found in other things
is that one person will die and suddenly
the
like the emf will go off or something
well i wonder if that's because when
someone dies your sanity drops
maybe
so maybe maybe certain things only
happen when you're at a certain level of
society
[Music]
uh
i was gonna say something but
i forgot
because i was listening to everything
in my bluetooth headset just on the
toilet like
interesting
the weather am i right
[Laughter]
it was very good you did very good thank
you thank you
[Laughter]
all right we going again
uh oh that's what i want to do i just
want to have a quick look at the charity
and see uh how we are
okay
so we are still at oh no no we've got
more we've got more um okay so
we are now up to 881 pounds for women's
trash which is absolutely bloody crazy
honestly i started off with a goal of
400 and then we went up to um 800.
i can't believe this
uh oh thank you jaded scientist that's
one of your friends right uh the person
who did dnd for
um ten pounds thank you so much oh mega
steak man as well thank you for twenty
dollars thank you jack t for fifteen
pounds and oh that's jet man
for twenty five dollars oh
good eggs thank you
phasmo the phobias i believe in y'all
that's what megan said
you said they got their uh
second vaccination shot
oh yeah yeah i hope i hope you are
feeling feeling rough yeah i hope you
recover quickly hopefully for most
people i don't know how it was with you
tom but for me it was like a the day
after 24 hours after was like awful but
then after that it was just kind of like
an achy arm so it didn't
i had no side effects oh that's
either of the shots
i had like a little bit of a i had a bit
of a headache after the first one
ah
it's very good and a sore arm
yeah yeah the um i mean that's a given
but yeah
i i i was kind of looking forward to
feeling sorry for myself to be honest
there's a part of me that was a bit like
oh quite looking forward to laying in
bed with no like with an actually good
excuse to like just lay there but no i
feel so rubbish where
it it was horrible though so like it you
got i mean a lot of people i know got
like um chills and shivers and like
fever and stuff so you can't sleep and
you're too hot and then too cold and you
oh it's just horrible
but
it doesn't last too long it lasts
usually just for 24 hours so
in that case if you're if you're lurking
and listening me goo i hope your side
effects are over shortly um yeah
okey dokey let's have a look what's up
let's keep this uh
keep this going hey champions let's go
do we need
it looks like we've got enough stuff
you got one motion sensor that should be
enough
yeah
okay
i can see your eyeballs brayden
how am i looking
um
pretty honestly
around halfway they turn into just like
flat
mono colored cubes
wow
until until you're inside the skull and
then they get a bit weird
all right i'm bringing emf and spirit
box
okay i'll be the photographer again with
the camera
uh
oh what's up what's up
it's the silver torch the
high-powered one
no it's the shitty one oh
i've been using the wrong torch
it looks so silvery and shiny though
yeah that's exactly what i did yeah it
looks banged up as well though it looks
banged up okay one of our objectives is
the crucifix
oh i've still got one slot
does someone have this we're going to
bring in more what's this emf is this
what's this
i've got temperature
is that what that is temperature yeah
yeah
emf and spirit box yeah okay i'll take a
matrix thing does someone have
a noise thing i don't remember that well
that was called
uh
i can take wait which one do we need one
a square i'll take this
this thing
i'll take a crucifix
oh this is emf ah whatever we have two
air mf no we won't i will i'll get
michael williams
hey at least respond to everyone
i'll get a
a dot
oh no
wait oh i chose the same cabin again
did i
have we been here the before
that's the scary part
i forget the names so i probably i
accidentally picked the same one
wherefore art doubt
oh a diploma
oh food competition
pumpkin soup hell yeah
i want that helena spooky seasoning
helena burgenton made some good pumpkin
soup
guaranteed awards that's not michael
handshake
oh
this is who michael killed
helena oh
michael kills helena
oh michael what are you doing right
though
a voodoo doll
where are you brayden where's the voodoo
doll
i'm upstairs
yeah i don't know if that's
to do with anything
the flashlight oh three
hello
i hear something
even f3 up here it's like here where's
the voodoo doll
i was in that bedroom over here this way
hey michael why are you killing people
if you pick it up and like drop it or at
least this is before the update it used
to like move around
oh cool
[Music]
let me drop this and then i'll pick it
up tomato soup
video games michael did you kill someone
about pumpkins
michael definitely did stop stop killing
people
hello cutie
where should we put you
oh there's another upstairs
oh the creepy ass bathroom
it's just like this what's this is this
a fly
yeah
maybe maybe michaels are flying
that's stupid
[Laughter]
just the vibes are wrong you know
where is it
feng shui
give us a sign it's quite a nice attic
did you throw the voodoo doll yes in the
corner there
i wonder
so it just used to pop up around the
house
yeah if you like picked up and threw it
around it would like oh my god yeah it's
right there it's here i did not throw it
here
wait let me try again
michael
i don't know nothing happened
michael but i didn't try it downstairs
there okay
maybe by the way all the dots [__]
rain's been quiet for a while
he's still down there i don't trust that
he dies so quietly as well he's just
like okay
okay let's see
there's also an axe in this mirror uh
michael i think it's michael oh is it
michael
it's in the journal now
yeah michael williams okay
michael williams where are you we got i
mean we got an emf three here but that
was eight again that's something there
was a lot of activity like a minute ago
but it's gone back down michael oh that
must have been you wanna answer
questions
can you turn the light off i'm gonna
bring i'm gonna get something else to
bring in
michael are you a cool guy
michael do you feel indifferently about
tomatoes
uh can i get to the front of the house
we're raising money for
cheers
this is very spoopy yes it is mush
mush
i'm sorry 11 i'm sorry i just totally
butchered your name where is the front
of this bloody house
aha here we are
what's class is a good showroom
condition torch hello
all right hello there
oh hello
okay what else would we need activities
so i get oh as we leave
wait is is
is jenny not in here where's ginny gone
jenny's in there still jenny are you in
there oh is jenny dead did anybody just
died uh oh
okay i've got a camera so i'm gonna put
it up there somewhere
and they can watch it like a little
movie
oh [__]
oh yeah
too late
[Music]
oh no where's jenny
jenny
daddy
where's the other dead person
i know i'm not alone in here
where'd she go
i just saw chat she's playing okay
the ghost pick gotcha the part is the
right one to do
yes
oh it's right clicking okay
oh no
michael are you here
she's just hitting me by this pillow
here so sad
michael give us a sign
i'm hearing noises over here brayden
they're throwing cans at me
the voodoo dolls in here look
oh cool
the moody's all actually moved oh my
gosh wait no is it is it not still up
here let's put this down
oh no oh it did move as well wait no it
didn't it's still here there's just a
multiple one maybe that's not a voodoo
doll then
[Music]
take a picture
michael give us a sign
they hunted us before we were even
in the spooky area
michael
hello
[Laughter]
i went in as soon as you died and then
died as well
oh
what's your [__] not what
are you getting so
oh
also they found another voodoo doll so i
don't is that actually a foodie doll
can there be two in like a house you can
hear it oh i don't know
oh they're not they're not gonna notice
the running water are they
oh my god that's so bright
[Laughter]
go to the light
all right
michael are you here
[Laughter]
michael give us a sign
michael michael michael come get braden
oh michael
maybe our sanity's too high now
[Music]
thank you so much everyone uh you press
the keyboard i think
i'm pressing the keyboard
where'd he go
dub my stuff tap my stuff dump my stuff
hi husband what getting cold
temperatures
oh my god that's spooky
wait are you dead too
yeah not that cool wait no tom's not
dead oh right
but the house isn't old enough oh he
just he just stole my can oh i see okay
he walks so casually like his animation
is so casual
[Laughter]
so it's yours jenny all of our amazing
just don't give a [__]
where's
braden
[Music]
we got strength for four
strengths of ten brain
[__] me [__] me [__] me
oh no
that's
over the table
that's horrific
oh my gosh
i love it though because it actually
killed you just over by the wall and
then suddenly you just like changed
position to being on this table in like
a horrific manner
[__] arty bruh i know right
i hope tom finds you like this
not bent over a table i don't think so
what are you saying
oh is he gonna leave
the scene is so dramatic it's so good
no yeah they're going i just heard the
van
we're going to haunt the space for all
eternity
or not
not all that's graphic
welcome back we're here
ready what the [__] is the twins no
but iron is all one
apparently they mimic each other or
something oh okay so maybe that's why we
thought one was upstairs and one was
downstairs i don't know
i'm not really i'm not really playing
with this i was it was so sad to hear as
i got back into the house i could hear
the gurgling death sounds of your body
but i had no idea where you were
and i was watching the strength thing
and it went to four and i was like brain
brayden you're in trouble
no you're dead the way he died was
actually really cool i was kind of
hoping you'd come in to see but
basically he got killed against a wall
and then all of a sudden his body just
switched positions to be sprawled out on
a table and axe through the mirror and
then broken shards all over his head i
was like that's good
yeah
it was pretty dramatic
well we didn't get that one but
i didn't die
you were the only survivor
celebration flashlight
now poor as well
oh yeah
i don't know how much money i have let's
have a look you click bobby
oh okay
don't mind
in comparison to you i am the sugar
[Laughter]
have you mama
i've got 1 700.
it's not even that much more but in
comparison
is there anything we need because i've
got 686 so i could buy stuff before you
stuff
why are they feeling rich
[Laughter]
because we're taking photos of their
corpses mate they get insurance
yeah i got more money from insurance
than i have done in a while
it's more profitable to die
i guess that is america
all right i'm ready when you are okay
i'm gonna try and
the thing is i always forget which
houses i've already done i wish you
could kind of look at your history
yeah make sure you don't go back to the
same place yeah
uh
should we try a bigger place or stick to
houses
i don't mind
i i would probably lean towards like
medium to large houses rather than like
the big big places
same because we're still getting smashed
on these little places
little okay lady
i want to know what evidence we were
supposed to have got for
the twins because we got nothing in that
yeah
i don't know it's [__] hard now yeah
okay
i'm ready when you are
let's do it
i can hear someone walking
ominous
okay
maria
oh do we know how many head cams welcome
back rick's alive
nope
oh no sorry
no they're like 60 quid they're like
really [__] expensive
in comparison to everything else
uh all right i'm gonna have a
temperature
and a delay i've got an emf this time
i'll take the dots
i'll take a spirit box in a book salt as
well
i actually know if no one's got a camera
then i'll take i'll take it i'll bring
the i'll bring the camera to put it down
okay sweet
oh i mean the photo camera
oh no not the photo i could take that oh
nice
uh so we need to oh we need to get it to
blow out a candle
we need emf so i've got that
maria
oh robinson
wow that's terrible oh that's so cool
look at that i love that
that's really cool
it's good money upstairs
art game
yeah
oh we've we've been here before
this is the place that uh jenny took me
around to
look at the
controls ah
the tutorial house
[Music]
oh my god is playing the piano
[Laughter]
what's his name
wow
i swear i just heard knocking on my
bedroom door
[Music]
all right maria maria
who likes to respond to people who are
alone again
maria why the ghosts only appeared one
example
i like your cat photos
can you move the door
maria where you at
oh yeah you a party person i can't
i don't think it's upstairs
no me neither
maria do you play piano where are they
are they downstairs
i think so
can you hear me through the floor
oh
chilly temperatures
[Music]
i know cena bun
did someone just play the piano
i played the guitar
oh okay
what's one plus two
maria how do you spell your name nobody
likes math you're just angry
give me a sign
describe a tomato to me hello oh oh oh
i think it's here
how much was that
only two
not much
where is it in here
oh oh five five we got five emf oh
[__] some evidence at last
okay yeah it's five degrees in here not
super cold but
i don't know if it's at the garage or
like no i think it's i think it's this
bit okay oh that cup just fell off i
guess i know someone said oh yeah
you can take a photo of those things and
it counts all those fingerprints on the
door as well on the light switch even
oh do you have you have the camera right
i think
okay that's the salt then
can you touch the lights again
wait what what i think
is the i was just asking the ghost to
touch
was that me did i stand in this or the
ghost
no no sure oh was it just now i'd
literally just put it down
okay yeah go get more stuff hello mr
pumpkin man
oh you said it
yeah i've seen all this oh crap jenny's
gone away we got we got some old
it's not a 10. oh no it's jimmy
yeah because i think we've got three
pieces of evidence right what do we get
we can join
an orbs
did it did he go up to
five
uh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
he still goes off and you saw
fingerprints right
yeah should we do the candle or should
we just leave
uh i've had to go and sort out the
objectives okay let's do that
what does this
ghost not like
okay have a member of your team
rarely leave a trace
how does that make sense it's just
fingerprints
yeah and it stood in the salt like
straight away
uh
who has a candle
maybe bradenton did you take your candle
i took a lighter in hoping oh
oh apparently a candle is there right
here
yep
blow out the candle
mariah
[Laughter]
does that work does that count if the
candle was already there and we didn't
put it in here
oh yeah
oh for sure
i mean maria
there's a footstep
this is another candle that you want me
to like
oh
oh it just did it
it's just blue oh sweet
cheers maria
okay
we've got to witness a ghost event now
if we want to all the stuff but if not
we've just lived
didn't you know what a cup move was that
surely i just witnessed a candle being
blown out that's not a ghost event
yeah i don't even count towards the
thing
i'm witnessing something right now i
don't know
maria how do you feel about candles
there's such a strong hand crucifix just
shadow on the wall
oh yeah
well it's gone there's no emf now
maria show yourself
maria how do you feel about
the stock market right now
oh she likes it she did that wasn't me
i didn't do the piano
she's into the stock market
yeah oh [__] oh [__]
oh she wants you to shout out oh she cut
the election
is there is this a is this a bone on the
table
or maybe
she's playing the piano again yeah
it's literally on the table there's a
bone on the table that's the big one
pick it up
i want us to start the game everyone to
see they want to see
look how [__] stupidly placed that is
it's just chilling on the table
maria that's a weird place to keep your
bones
what do you mean she was done with the
meal do you love the word on the plate
five on the emf
where the frick is she
stay away from my friends
maria
maria maria maria what's going on give
us a sign
ask a [__] like that
give us a sign
maria maria give us a sign
play the piano
activity
well the light won't turn on now and i
can't see anything because i'm inside
your skull oh put the breaker back on
no that's scary
maria play the piano
oh
it's nice
can you show yourself please
give us a thumbs up
can you use the crucifix if it's burned
is it burnt there's a big burn
yeah
i think it works like i don't think
there was
oh okay yeah it like degrades more i
think there wasn't like a haunting
though right so it's really wood only
well it
did it was on the floor at one point
because that's how it gets rid of the
horns right
no oh yeah it block it blocks the
haunting from happening happening oh
yeah so it wasn't typical
though it was intact on the floor though
but
i don't know
maybe it works in your hands now maybe
it does
oh
now it's gotten very red since i threw
through on the floor
oh maria roberts
i've got more money i can't do it
she thinks i'm talking to her wish i
could look through the window
are you guys playing
[Music]
oh yeah
make sure you've got your ghost down on
your journal book
what is it oh yeah obi yeah gotcha
mistakes were made mistakes were made
um
[Music]
i just wanted to take the big share of
tom
that was stupid
you ran so far and
oh i thought i was safe i thought i made
it i just wanted to quickly take a
picture of you and then go and then i
was like nope
oh okay
ah
big murdered
[Music]
you got chased down by the scary crawly
lady too oh yeah i was a crawly one
he was one of the crawly ones
i didn't actually see her
i just hid
i thought if i turned off my light and
then looked at a cabinet then she
wouldn't see me
i don't know how it seems to be hard to
hide now yeah really hard
at least from my experience of watching
people
hmm
do you think yeah
yeah
yeah because they can
sense equipment more now
so i don't know whether talking on the
radio is a good idea either
like even people talking to us on the
radio i don't know whether that's a good
thing or not
like i don't know
because you used to just cut radios out
completely but now
now it seems to be more i don't know
more prevalent
maybe someone in chat knows but i don't
know
okay
well it's getting near the end of stream
time so do you want to do one more or
four more yeah yeah
okay sweet yeah um i have money jenny if
you want me to buy some stuff
so yeah it's okay
i didn't i didn't die that time so i
still have some stuff like that
nice nice
uh is there anything that we need
what did we have last time was it the
head flashlights
uh
yes i can buy
a couple of those i've got i just bought
one what are they called
oh headmaster head vantage camera
i'll get a candle just in case we didn't
have one
i said maria too many times
she made me
i want a new house again but i don't
know which one's in there
okay let's try this one let's try this
one
okay
i'm ready to die again
that's
[Laughter]
maria was very uncivilized that she was
oh hello that's close
everybody
[Music]
can it's back
does everyone does someone has the emf
right
oh i've got a camera
i'll take a picture where are you
i'm
oh yes oh it's like a dinosaur bone bone
just keeps moving this door i'm just
gonna turn the breaker on
[Music]
oh wait uh i need to take a picture but
i've got the camera as well um
i think you can take it anyway and the
game just knows that it's
okay let's hope
uh
yeah fingerprints yeah knows it's there
oh okay hacks
evidence fingerprints
hey kenneth i'm gonna go grab some stuff
how do you feel about hot cross buns
[Laughter]
kenneth give us a sign
kenneth how old are you
oh my
kenneth do you like
tom
i wait so
he's we've got spirit box and
fingerprints that means he's a phantom
or a poltergeist
poltergeists throw stuff
fingerprints
oh yeah possibly
phantoms
drop your sanity fast
okay we don't need this one anymore
let's take some pills because why not
what do we have
uh we've got
syrup
i'm bringing
motion sensor
how old are you kenneth
oh we got a crucifix down on the
book will that cancel out
oh is the shower running
what the shower's running
in here
oh i'll take a picture
oh hold on
let's put that there like we're
intruding
kenneth are you trying to have a shower
at least he's a hygienic ghost canis
please put some clothes back on
i want to hear it we need
if you pick up the spirit box it might
be a bit more responsive to you
okay
what are your pronouns
uh
where are you
what year is it
old
do you like me
can you talk to me
oh was it not saying evan
[Music]
what's your favorite color
do you like pizza
i don't know what
[Music]
how did you die
are you dead
where are you
why are you ignoring me
kenneth where are you
kenneth why are you ignorant
in that bedroom
kenneth do you like cats
kenneth
how did you die
kenneth are you going to kill us
oh my god [__] jesus christ i don't
want this
he's making weird noises does he make a
croaking noise right now he's a very old
person old old ghosty
did he run the book i'm old
leave me alone i'm old
kenneth do you like tomatoes
ask him how he died a full essay about
pumpkins
kenneth how did you die
yeah
kenneth did you die
old age
oh jesus
oh
okay
oh he just said kill oh kill okay okay
uh
kenneth could you walk over our dots
projector please
oh wow oh that's smoke sticks
he likes me he really likes like kitty
do you like me
i did i cleansed it
nice
what does that mean i don't know
objective then
uh
we didn't get emf5 did we
no well all we need now is because we we
got fingerprints right and we got
we got spirit box
which means in the evidence thing
oh he said death
oh i thought he said yes he's like
joining in yeah
[Music]
wait no we don't
i thought we had one where's the
crucifix gone
oh it's out here oh
should we put it in the room
let's put it in the room
okay put that back in the room we need
to prevent it from the objective
oh okay
kenneth tell me more about yourself bro
kenneth are you are you a writer
kenneth how do you feel about dots
projectors
kenneth how old were you when dot's
projectors were invented
oh
how old how can how old do you like your
lovers
malice mortis thinks his mumbling sounds
more like farts so he's just passing on
us
he's like oh kenneth isn't that dirty of
an old man kev had a shower it's not
gonna go oh that's very true
although he did have a shower in full
vision of all of us
yeah
no shame no shame
a bit of shame
that's pretty gross kind of
because
we need you to write in this book or we
need you to be doctor we also need uh
him in the motion sensor which is here
oh yeah
where's the car
our hypothesis is that we need to have
lower brains and jenny's brain is a 91
but the rest of us are around 40 to 50
so we need to get low brains
[Music]
what if we had a rave in your bedroom
kenneth
can it
[Laughter]
i love that
i was trying to see if i can get the
dutch projector to do something
but
we've not got any dots but we've also
not gonna be writing and no emotions
show yourself
wait are you saying he's in this room
oh yeah because wait why are we saying
things in this room
something happened i had so much
confidence
well this door was open and then all the
[__] happened
right
oh yeah the shower did go
yeah the shower went off
you move a door
give us a sign
kenneth you naughty do something
oh my god you angered it
oh [__] i'm dead
oh god
no she died at the front door kenneth
you bastard
and he has hit in the cupboard
oh he just stood on this he just stood
on this here huh
i just saw him stand in this salt
i didn't see him in the dots
[__]
on yours
wait so did we get him with the motions
where's the book
should be in the room
ugh no
we still haven't prevented him from
hunting with a crucifix either
he's
someone just died
oh no
where are you do you wanna come back
oh my god
[Music]
tom's dead come come to the front door
oh my god no no no no don't listen to me
hide
oh my god
oh brayden
oh [__]
damn
[__] oh [__]
oh [__]
is he dead
you sound like zero percent sanity
oh [__]
no
they're all dead
i'm all there besides other
i think it's a phantom
[__] it
let's go
bye oh my god that's
terrifying
what the hell
oh
wow
[Laughter]
[Music]
that question about whether we were sure
if it was in there apparently i was
[__] right to follow that lead
because he wasn't even spawning in that
bathroom he was what was he not
no he was spawning in the room like
adjacent to it but like
around the corner oh right
okay well he was nearby we kind of we
kind of got it
hmm we were like well we were close yeah
but we still lost three people and
oh i know i was at the front door and
i'd opened it and i just saw jenny at
the front and then i was like okay
brayden come to the front door and then
all of a sudden the door just slammed in
my face and i was like no don't come to
the front door
like additionally
so i really do think it must be linked
to like everyone's sanity so the second
that jenny sanity was dropped down from
90.
because we were all like at the same
sanity until but like jenny was like at
90 something so it must take like an
average
yeah it does yeah or it did for sure
well brayden lie at the end there we're
literally like one percent and then it
went down to zero percent so i was like
i need to go now
i can go back in there yeah
oh well that was fun
that was fun
i actually yeah really enjoy that
because last time we played it i think
we just got too used to it and we found
it quite like no but that was really fun
it's very scary
yeah yeah for sure yeah i definitely
seem to have uh made it a bit different
more difficult from what i was used to
watching previously
how did you find it tom for your first
time playing oh yeah that was all right
it was okay i enjoyed it
not as spooky as you thought it would be
i mean there were definite moments when
i was on my own and i was like well [__]
this is spooky
but uh no i mean i'm understood
it's definitely scarier with the in-game
audio as well because i've only played
it before with like discord and it's
kind of cheating
well i'm glad you gave it a shot and
that you found it to be rewarding yeah
no it's very good
yeah i think it adds an extra layer to
it which is you know a bit more spooky
and fun
having people whisper in your ears
[Laughter]
i can't i can't believe the first
jumpscare was freaking in here as well
oh gosh
i'm so glad i just found that on my own
without like
knowing yeah yeah i'm really glad that
you didn't like you didn't you weren't
even following up by it
oh it's so good
oh the man up here is so creepy too i
love it it's so pt vibes
it's it's it's creepy because it's just
scary it's just casual you know yeah and
it doesn't even attempt to move it's
just like that's about that
and yet it's always watching you
i'm under the cabin help me
what's supposed to happen when i do this
oh it just falls out
it doesn't make any noise either when it
falls it's silent
that's why there's no clutch anything
and then this is this book i don't know
i still don't like it it's so loud
i hate jump scares
[Music]
all right
all ggs
happy halloween
um
you're doing a special like halloween
d string
we're playing an hour our usual weekly
sunday d game
uh
that jenny hosts on her twitch channel
an idm for it
and we're all doing a super duper budget
cosplay
of the characters in our game oh cool
one of which so jenny's character is a
goblin so she's going to be all green
yeah
yeah i drew the short straw i didn't
realize we were gonna be cosplaying this
one
one of our one of our players uh jack is
playing as a total so it's a turtle
person who has a big shell
nice guys and we have a monk who's gonna
be wearing a a bold cap it's going to be
very good
whereas i i'm playing as a jenny's
character is a ranger with a
honduran bat as an animal companion
so i'm cosplaying as a bat
nice do you have do you have wings
sort of
[Laughter]
budget wings
they're gonna be they're gonna be
attached to the back of the chair i'm
just
it's it's but it's super budget but yeah
we'll be over there but but also
congratulations on raising so much money
thank you thank you that's awesome such
a good cause as well wow 881 pounds
i know let me let me just double check
but um yeah i've just put jenny's uh
twitch channel in the chat so check it
out if you want to check out that ninjas
and dagons it's sleepiest underscore
uh yeah 881 pounds it's so good
it's a good amount good yeah it's very
good it's crazy
right wow
i'm sorry if it's a bit awkward
goodbye
um
anything else that anyone wants to plug
i know jenny is also an amazing artist
so check out is it are you sleepiest
underscore on everything or is it
underscore on instagram as well
sleepiest uh on twitter it's underscore
but on instagram it's sleepiest designs
just to be awesome
gotcha
she does the
most adorable cute like designs ever and
in the future there'll be emotes for
this channel done by the wonderful jenny
so you you have that to look forward to
as well
[Laughter]
all right cool okay okay let's i gotta
pee let's go okay
okay
bye everyone
yeah bye-bye
oh
that was cute
okay i'm on my own i don't want to be on
my own right okay
boo let's go to me main
cool right
i will end the stream by shutting down
this game
oh
taking off the headphones very nice
and i'll have a little chat with you
so
that is the end of the halloween stream
i can't believe it's been what like
eight hours worth streaming and it's
been so good maybe seven and a half i
don't know something like that but it's
been so good and now i need to do what i
what i told you that i would do um
why did i say i would do this i don't
even know if you're still in the chat
because i think it was michael who said
it but uh yeah i need to
fly like a witch
but thank you so much to everyone who
has donated
881 pounds raised for women's trust
that's absolutely
mental
let me just figure this out one sec
um
legit what was that knocking sound
no
no what
what is that necklace oh amy got me this
necklace
uh she got it for my birthday i think i
opened it on stream
um
no
shut up no
no that's actually creepy because i
thought i heard it from the bedroom as
well
are you are you messing with me
but
i don't know you shouldn't be
come see it
okay i said i was gonna go and pretend
to fly on a broom i don't have a broom
though what can i use
i'm not gonna use the guitar i'm not
gonna use a guitar because i'll probably
end up breaking it
i absolutely love this cape so so much
fun
um what can i use
let's just use this
my tripod
no that's not witchy
where is my dignity where did it go i
don't know
i don't know
there you go that's my thank you
for all of you lovely people helping me
to raise money for women's trust
i hope you enjoyed
flying in a broomstick
ah the door knock sound no it's so
creepy you don't
that's like the frame flamethrower
matching like
a witch fbs
ah
okay i i'm gonna say goodbye now
but yeah this halloween has been awesome
thanks to you all it's been such a good
halloween and yeah just honestly thank
you so much
for
helping me raise so much money
for women's trust
it's just crazy that we had to move the
goal post two times
um if anyone wants to make any uh
last-minute donations then feel free
to i've just put the link in the chat
um
i'll probably leave it up until the end
of halloween just in case you know
anyone else wants to or anyone missed
the opportunity to um
i feel like really blustered now
blasted plastered blasted blistered
blustered plastered
blusted is that a word
yeah i think it is
um
but anyway hey badass domian do i take
game quests um i do on on discord if you
follow my discord
um i'll give you a discord link just in
case anyone is watching and not on the
discord because we have the most amazing
supportive kind wonderful discord
community
so let me just get that
invitation for you all
um but yeah it's been so much fun we've
we've have done so much
we've played fatal frame we've played
phasmaphobia we had some chatting and
played loads of songs for you all
um
it's been so good
there's the discord link i just put it
in the chat for you
can confirm flustered is a word
flustered flustered there you go yeah
well done take care of all thank you so
much again colin on you have been yeah
this much is you basically you have been
the charity stream mvp so thank you so
much colin really appreciate it and it's
nice to see you here cause i know you
miss a lot of the streams so it's nice
that you could make make this one so
that's good
thoroughly enjoyed the stream sorry i
couldn't donate i'm still no no okay if
you could not donate then thank you so
much for just being with me and watching
i mean it's so amazing how much we were
able to raise but just you spending
halloween with me it's honestly enough
so thank you very much don't worry about
it at all and i'm glad you enjoyed this
stream i'm glad that you could have a
bit of fun time in the stream as well
because that was the whole point of this
like i said at the beginning i
still
you know i'm not 100
uh comfortable being like around lots of
people so i was like i want to do
something fun for halloween
so i thought well i'm sure i'm not the
only one who's kind of adjusting to
reality and doesn't have anything to do
on halloween um because a lot of things
are still closed as well so
i thought well
let's do a live stream we can all hang
out together and
we can raise some money for charity
because
why not
so yeah i think it ended up
really good
will we good
okay i'm gonna say goodbye to who i can
see in the chat actually i'll just
refresh this one one time just to make
sure
even though i can technically i can see
it above my head because it's right
there above my head
but yeah i will see you next thursday 8
30 pm bst where we will be continuing
with alan wake um as for
fatal frame
make sure that you're followed on my
discord i'll let you know what's
happening if i complete fatal frame
it'll hopefully
be on twitch and i'll only stream on
twitch because i'm going to try
a little trial of just streaming on
twitch and not youtube and i'll see how
how i like it because i wanna have all
the benefits of twitch affiliate and
yeah try that out
um
but yeah okay
so thank you again for spending the
evening with me it's been really nice uh
i hope you have a great halloween
and maybe go and watch a spooky movie
now maybe go and read a scary book um
my favorite scary book is the haunting
of hill house by shirley jackson i
actually love shirley jackson i only
found a found her recently in the last
couple of years and
wow
her writing she's so she writes such
like short succinct stories i mean her
short story the lottery is very well
known um but yeah she's she's really
good she's really good
i love her
and i might be watching i don't know but
i might be watching the exorcist tonight
but i don't know all depends on how
brave i feel because i watched the
exorcist when i was really really tiny
in
a roman catholic school
and it scared me and i could not sleep
for three months because you know i was
quite religious and i totally believed
it and i was really scared that it was
all gonna happen to me so i haven't
watched it since and then i'm thinking
maybe i should watch it again just so
you know i get over my fears but at the
same time
i don't know i'm scared i'm scared i
don't know
uh but anyway
i'm going to say goodbye to i can see
the chat so
goodbye jamie goodbye 8196. goodbye clay
goodbye mantas goodbye malachi goodbye
kieran white oh no you joined back too
late no
goodbye
um
jandio goodbye
[Music]
uh
bergy saying bye right before i go into
work have a good day or night at work i
hope that goes okay
bye
eternal cheesecake
what a name what a name that's an
awesome name
by uh
i think that's everything i think that's
everything
by officer naruto
by colin williams if you're still here
yeah i think that's it and goodbye to
anyone who i haven't seen in the chat
even though i think i have and goodbye
to anyone who isn't in the chat and is
just watching as always i really
appreciate you being here as well see
you next thursday 8 30 p.m bst